Die zwei Sprechstunden.
I-I-I-I-D-I-I-X-C-D-I-I-I-I-D-I-I-X-C-D-I-X-C-D-I-X-C-D-I-X-C-D-I-
Und dann ist es wieder soweit. Der letzte Donnerstag am Monat ist herangekommen. Malen nach Zahlen im Radio, denn der Chaos Computer Club ändert dieses Studio für die nächsten zwei Stunden. Es ist das Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, wo über ein Thema gesprochen wird, das im weitesten Sinne irgendwie mit Technik und Dingen, die darum entstehen, die Verantwortlichkeit, die Konsequenzen, die möglicherweise Zukunftsszenarien. So auch heute. Heute geht es um etwas, das sich auf den ersten Blick etwas tödlich anhört. Es geht um Kriegsmaschinerien und wir werden mal genauer klären wollen, was jetzt dieses ganze Technikdingen damit zu tun hat. Zu Gast sind heute Frank Rieger, hallo und guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Der Herr Erdgeist, hallo und guten Abend.
Herr Wunderschön, guten Abend.
Und überraschenderweise ganz plötzlich noch mit dem Studio, obwohl fast gar nicht zu sehen Rob. Hallo und guten Abend. So, nur um den aktuellen Aufhänger, weil das machen wir bei den Medien gerne auch zu haben. Es geht heute auch um und im großen Teil um Drohnen. Also die Dinger, die ihr vielleicht von privat kennt. So diese vier Rotoren kann man irgendwie mit dem Tablet Computer bedienen. Die gibt es auch in groß, die benutzt auch das Militär. Die sind auch in den Medien gewesen. Immer dann, wenn es wieder einen Präzisionsschlag gab, dann war das auch mit Drohntechnik manchmal gemacht. Und darüber wollen wir heute reden. Und unter anderem auch, wie es überhaupt dazu gekommen konnte und welche Leute das machen. Und damit wollen wir, wie es im Chaos Radio ja manchmal üblich ist, ganz am Anfang anfangen. Also, um quasi zu sagen, Nerds bauen Kriegsmaschinerie. Warum? Und wer war der Erste? Wer ist der Bekannteste?
Der Erste und der Bekannteste sind nicht derselbe. Na ja, also so richtig angefangen hat das mit Archimedes. Der hatte damals, um seine Heimatstadt zu verteidigen, diverse Ideen sich einfallen lassen, wie da feindliche Heere, die dort per Schiff ankommen, zum Beispiel davon abgehalten werden können, die Küste zu erreichen. Und hat dann somit ein paar Ablenkspiegeln, die auf die Sonne gerichtet waren und so ausgerichtet waren, dass sie die Segel der ankommenden Schiffe treffen, hat erst geschafft mehrere Schiffe in den Brand zu stecken. Das gab lange Zweifel, ob das wirklich funktioniert. Bis dann wirklich 2007 Wissenschaftler das versucht haben, mal nachzubauen. Der erste Versuch ist gescheitert, aber 2007 haben Wissenschaftler geschafft, mit so 107 kleinen Spiegeln ein mittleres bis kleines Segel eines Schiffs in den Brand zu setzen.
Das heißt, weiß man wirklich, ob das historisch korrekt war, dass da sozusagen eine geniale Seele, dass man damals alles universal Genährte losgezogen ist und Kriegsmaschinerie gebaut hat?
Das ist geschichtlich belegt, dass viele Wissenschaftler natürlich dann besonders nützlich gewesen sind, wenn sie nicht nur theoretische Erkenntnisse, also sozusagen die Fundamente der Wissenschaft, ausbaldovert haben, sondern dann auch gleich ganz nützliche Applikationen. Und wenn du dich gegen fremde, anrückende Horden irgendwie zur Wehr setzen musst, um da dein, naja, hochdemokratisch entwickeltes Leben dort weiter zu bestreiten, dann bist du natürlich da auch angehalten, deine Erkenntnisse, deine Wissenschaft in den Dienst der Verteidigung deiner Stadt zu stellen.
Was man noch beachten muss, ist, dass damals natürlich Wissenschaft sehr viel weniger theoretisch als heute waren, doch sehr viel näher an Kunst und an Handwerk war, als zum Beispiel heute so ein theoretischer Physiker ist. Eigens, wenn man zum Beispiel mal wieder so ans Zorn guckt, zum Beispiel zum Teilchenbeschleuniger, dann haben die da auch schon erhebliche Mengen Hardware, also es geht wieder sozusagen im Kreis herum, dass die theoretischen Physiker sich dann plötzlich wieder mit der Materie beschäftigen müssen. Also die Frage halt, wer hat denn diese Kriegsmaschinen eigentlich gebaut und wer hat die dann so entwickelt, ist durch die Zeit kann man eigentlich sagen, dass eigentlich immer die wesentlichen Wissenschaftler der jeweiligen Zeit auch zumindest einen Teil ihres Lebens damit verbracht haben, Kriegsmaschinen zu entwickeln und zu bauen. Und die dann teilweise auch durchaus einen sehr erheblichen Einfluss darauf hatten, wie sich Geschichte entwickelt hat. Also wer zu der Zeit halt einen militärischen Vorteil hatte oder sich besser verteidigen konnte. Und man kann schon sagen, dass Technologie durch die Geschichte hinweg auch Kriege mitentschieden hat. Nicht nur ausschließlich, aber durchaus auch ein entscheidender Faktor war. Und dass Gegner, die halt signifikant unterlegen waren, technologisch in der Regel dann halt auch irgendwann verschwunden sind.
Was ging es denn nur darum, dass die Leute wirklich, also dass die Technik wirklich überlegen war oder dass auch die Feinde sozusagen einen Schrecken bekommen haben. Man baut einen riesigen Spiegel, man setzt damit einen Segel in den Brand. Das stell dich mir im militärstrategischen Sinne nicht besonders schlimm vor.
Naja, wenn du in der Lage bist, wir stellen uns mal kurz die damalige Zeit vor, also die höchste Technologie, also die Hochtechnologie, was es da gab, waren Katapulte mit relativ begrenzter Reichweite und noch mal relativ begrenzten Schadenspotenzial. Also was man da so hinkriegen konnte, war halt im Zweifel sowas wie griechisches Feuer schicken per Katapult. Und auch das war schon Hochtechnologie. Allein die Tatsache, dass man in der Lage war, flüssig Brandbomben in Form von Tontöpfen über Katapulte zu verschießen, war halt schon ein signifikanter Engineering-Fortschritt. Also das hatten nicht alle. Und wenn man sich dann anguckt, für wie lange das dann der Stand der Technik war. Also ich meine, es war halt so noch zu den Zeiten der Kreuzfahrer, also der ersten Kreuzzüge, also durchaus noch mal so richtig so 1.500 Jahre später, war es quasi dasselbe. Also da hatten die, war immer noch die wesentlichen Waffentechnologien, waren halt Katapulte und Langbogen und Spieße und Schwärter. Und halt irgendwie vielleicht ein bisschen besserer Rüstung und ein bisschen besserer Stahl.
Und da warst du dann aber zu sagen, da würde man ja jetzt vermuten, Kraft der Schulbildung, ha ha, und dann hat jemand das Schwarzpulver erfunden und fortan waren die Ritter Geschichte. Das ist ja nicht ganz so, sondern es gab da noch einen anderen Schritt, der wichtig ist.
Na, das Schwarzpulver war nun nicht der spannendste Teil. Weil der Schwarzpulver hat einen echten Nachteil, war nämlich, dass du nicht gucken konntest. Also das Schwarzpulver war lange Zeit sehr stark rauchend und bevor dann das rauchlose Schwarzpulver erfunden worden ist und ein paar Geschosse, die gleich das Pulver mit integriert hatten, also nicht einfach bloß ein paar Bleikugeln per Frontlader, die weggeschossen wurden, sondern die von hinten nachladbar waren, war das Schwarzpulver nicht so richtig doll nützlich. Also einen Kanon hat man da so Streufeuer machen können. Aber wo wolltest du denn hinaus?
Ich wollte auf die Industrialisierung hinaus sagen, dass das Schießpulver eigentlich der Punkt war, sondern der Punkt war, sozusagen, ein großem Maßstab.
Also muss ich kurz vergegenwärtigen, wie Kanonen damals funktioniert haben. Zu den Zeiten, als das Schwarzpulver erfunden wurde und kurz danach. Da waren Kanonen Unikate, die also gegossen wurden oder teilweise auch gebaut wurden, also aus Holzfragmenten mit Eisenreifen gebaut wurden, die ja alle so in relativ unterschiedlichen Durchmesser hatten. Und dann wurden die Kugeln für diese Kanonen per Hand auf Durchmesser gehämmert. Also in so Steinmetzarbeit.
Jede Kugel war Handarbeit?
Und wurden dann mit Lederlappen reingefropft, um eine halbwegs hohe Gasabdichtung. Man durfte es auch nicht übertreiben, sonst platzte wieder die Kanone. Und erst da, als man dann anfangen konnte, die in Serie zu gießen, dass die ungefähr alles selbe Kaliber hatten, also den Durchmesser der Kugel, da fing es dann an, dass es eine Waffe war, die man massenweise einsetzen konnte und die eine signifikante Überlegenheit außer einer psychologischen Abschreckung gegenüber einem Katapult hatte. Man sollte auch nicht unterschätzen, so einen Katapult, also auch Blieben genannt, diese großen Katapulte. Die haben zwar nur relativ selten geschossen, weil man immer lange Zeit gebraucht hat, sie zu spannen, aber dafür ziemlich treffgenauer und über sehr große Entfernung. Wenn man mehrere davon hatte und so eine Festung belagert hat, da konnte man schon einen ziemlich erheblichen Schaden anrichten. Die Beladung dieser Katapulte war durchaus eher kreativ. Die haben dann auch ihre toten Viecher und ihren Müll und ihre Leichen verschossen, um der Stadt oder der Festung, die sie belagert haben, da möglichst Schaden zu tun. Aber wir wollen ja eigentlich zurück zu dieser Innovation und den Wissenschaftlern.
Was ich jetzt gerade noch fragen wollte, ist zu sagen, da war es im weitesten Sinne Handwerk. Also eine geniale Idee und ein gutes Handwerk. Und jetzt ist ja der Chaos Computer Club und die Sendung hier ist sozusagen eher der Technik. Das heißt, man kann sagen, Algorithmen, also Mathe und bestimmte Dinge, die berechnet werden können. Wann schließt sich dieses Ding? Wann werden Leute, die tatsächlich einfach, ich sage mal jetzt in Anführungszeichen, nicht viel mehr als wirklich gut rechnen können? Ab wann haben die für Kriegsführung eine Rolle gespielt?
Na, Isaac Newton ist für vieles bekannt gewesen, was so wie weniger bekannt war, dass er dort auch der englischen Armee die Durchschlagskraft von Geschossen durch Mauerwerk und alle möglichen Verteidigungen ausgerechnet hat, um ihnen da den Vorteil zu verschaffen. Leonhard Euler hat Grundsätze der Artillerie wirklich ausgerechnet auch von den Briten übernommen. Euler war so berühmter Schweizer Mathematiker. Und der hat dann auch der britischen Armee dort Forschung zurückgegeben und hat dann das erste Mal für Waffen längerer Reichweiten auch den Luftwiderstand in die ballistischen Formeln mit aufgenommen. Und dadurch hat sich die Treffgenauigkeit ganz massiv erhöht. Da Vinci ist ja auch eh bekannter dafür gewesen, so Mörser, Panzerwagen, Kanonen, Katapulte und Projektile zu bauen und soweit zu inginieren, dass ihm jeweils die Armeen die Vorteile hatte.
Da Vinci ist ja bekannt für, er hat einen Hubschrauber entworfen, aber das ist natürlich niemals gebaut worden. Hat er tatsächlich Dinge da entworfen, die zum Einsatz kamen?
Er hat dann praktisch Dinge entworfen, die dann zum Einsatz gekommen sind. Aber das ist wirklich alle Wissenschaftler, die einigermaßen berühmt sind, haben dann auch zu der Zeit ihren Beitrag geleistet zur Aufrüstung der Armee.
Wichtiger Punkt ist, glaube ich, die Wissenschaftler haben einen Beitrag zur Aufrüstung der Armee geleistet. Und dann haben wir in der Kriegsgeschichte das erste Vorkommnis, das wäre ohne Wissenschaft gar nicht möglich gewesen, die Atombombe.
Naja, ich weiß nicht, ob es das erste Vorkommnis war. Also auch vieles von dem, was vorher an industrialisierter Kriegsführung da war, wäre ohne wissenschaftlicher Forschung so nicht möglich gewesen. Also spätestens eigentlich seit, sagen wir mal, so Zündnall, Gewehr und rauchloses Pulver. Die waren halt schon Systeme, die halt durch Wissenschaft und Metallurgie entstanden sind. Dann sind noch zum Beispiel die Forschung, die Krupp gemacht hat, um Kanonstahl zu entwickeln. Die war schon sehr wissenschaftsorientiert und hatte also nicht mehr so viel mit Handwerk zu tun, sondern mit systematischer Wissenschaft. Bei der Atombombe ist der interessante Unterschied, dass es halt tatsächlich eine Waffe war, die zuerst vollständig in der theoretischen Physik skizziert und errechnet werden konnte. Also die halt als erstes tatsächlich eine Waffe war, die auf einem Blatt Papier existierte und dann mit einem immensen gigantischen Aufwand gebaut wurde. Und bei der die Wissenschaftler ja im Wesentlichen die waren, die es möglich gemacht haben. Also wo es halt nicht nur reicht, die Idee zu skizzieren und dann schickt man die Mythologen und die Handwerker los, um es zu machen, sondern es war halt notwendig, in einzelnen der Schritte, die dafür notwendig waren, eben auch mathematisch zu begleiten und da Physiker im Start zu haben, die halt auch so kürze kleine Probleme bei Atomtechnologie lösen, weil es völlig unintuitiv ist. Also schon alleine, wenn man halt anfängt, Plutonium zu schmelzen. Plutonium hat irgendwie eine Reihe von Aggregatszuständen, die alle vollständig unterschiedlich sind, die man berechnen muss, um zu wissen, wie es sich dann verhält. Die hängen davon ab, wie man es abkühlt und wie weit man es erhitzt und so weiter. Das ist halt nicht so wie mit Eis und dann schmilzt es und so, sondern viel komplizierter und da brauchst du dann natürlich eine Menge wissenschaftlicher Mathematik dafür. Aber seitdem, also wenn man die Atomburgung als arbeitliche Regenzierung einbringen will, kann man schon sagen, dass eigentlich seit dem zweiten Weltkrieg die Rolle der Wissenschaft in der Waffenentwicklung extrem groß und sichtbar wurde. Und war es vorher so, dass ja einzelne Wissenschaftler oder einzelne Genies waren, die halt in der Waffenentwicklung tätig waren, was denn so das signifikante Teile der Wissenschaftler in der Militärforschung tätig waren und halt auch so richtig eingebunden und essentiell sind.
Bevor wir dann zur jetzigen Zeit kommen, würde ich jetzt sozusagen auf das Metathema der Verantwortung und der Konsequenz kurz zu sprechen kommen wollen. Weil auch da war die Atomburgung, also für mich zumindest, wenn ich das jetzt sagen will, mit meinen bescheidenen historischen Kenntnissen, betrachtet das erste Mal, wo man dann feststellt, dass die Leute, die in dieser Waffe gearbeitet haben, sowas wie einen Gewissen hatten oder sich zumindest damit auseinandergesetzt haben, dass ihr Tun Konsequenzen hat. Bei der Atombombe gab es drei Geisteseinstellungen. Die einen, die gesagt haben, dass wir diese Atombombe bauen, ist super. Und wir berechnen auch gerne, in welcher Höhe wir die abwerfen, damit sie maximalen Schaden anrichtet. Also John von Neumann fällt mir da ein. Dann gibt es Wissenschaftler, die sagen, wir sind ja hier nur die Wissenschaftler quasi und haben das nur gebaut. Und was die Militärste machen, wissen wir auch nicht. Dann gibt es Leute, die sich auch dagegen ausgesprochen haben. Da war ja Einstein, glaube ich, dann auch am Ende mit dabei. Gab es das vorher schon? Also ist sozusagen von den Leuten die Namen, die jetzt gesagt haben, Archimedes, Da Vinci, Euler, Newton, haben die sich auch Gedanken gemacht? Oder waren das sozusagen eher so, muss man sich das so vorstellen, diese verschrobenen Genies, die dann halt so, hey, geil, lass mal bitte ausrechnen, wie ich ein entferntes Segelentbrand setze.
Da kann man sich jetzt echt schwer in die Leute hineinversetzen.
Gibt es da Berichte vielleicht?
Naja, es gibt natürlich schon ein paar. Also bei einigen Wissenschaftlern, gerade so das 19. Jahrhunderts und das Beginn des 20. Jahrhunderts, gab es durchaus auch die Überlegung, die es auch bei den Atombombenentwicklern gab, dass sie die ultimative Waffe entwickeln, die dann den Frieden bringt. Also, wonach Krieg halt dann sinnlos geworden ist. Also Berichte gibt es zum Beispiel von einigen Entwicklern von verschiedenen Maschinengewehren, die gesagt haben, okay, wir bauen jetzt die ultimative Waffe und danach ist Frieden. Von Alfred Nobel wird es berichtet, also der, der ein großes Sprengstoff quasi Monopol hatte, auch mit den Gewinnen daraus, die Nobelpreise finanziert hat. Von denen gibt es auch Berichte darüber, dass sie dachten, okay, wir entwickeln jetzt mal so noch die ultimative Waffe und dann ist Krieg sinnlos geworden und dann wird es dann nicht weiter. Gerade jetzt zum Beispiel die Entwicklung des TNT, also des ersten richtig handhabbaren, hochbrisanten Sprengstoffs. Vorher gab es halt so Schießbombenwolle, die halt so ein bisschen zickig ist und schwierig zu handhaben und wenn man jetzt halt einen Sprengstoff hat, der einfach zur Hand haben, einfach herzustellen und sicher zu zünden ist, da gab es dann halt eben die, die eine an sich, die sagte, ja danach wird Frieden sein, weil wir halt werden das in riesigen Mengen herstellen und das macht keinen Sinn mehr und die anderen sagten, naja, es wird dann ein Zeitalteres Terrorismus anbrechen. Alle Leute werden Bomben bauen und schmeißen, also die Anarchisten damals, die Anarchituristen damals. Und das ist interessanterweise, sind viele von diesen Diskussionen, die damals geführt wurden, sind heute auch in natürlich veränderter Form. Gibt es aber heute eben auch wieder.
Also das heißt aber, da war die Idee schon, die man aus dem Kalten Krieg von Atoma auch kennt, dass man sagt, wir entwickeln die perfekte Waffe und die so erschrecken, dann will eigentlich keiner mehr Krieg führen. Da hat man quasi die Menschheit ein bisschen überschätzt.
Das war dann einfach der Status quo damals gewesen, dass man jetzt die Menschheit mehrfach auslöschen könnte durch die vorhandenen Atomarnasenale, dass durch diese Abschreckungspolitik das dann einfach keinen Sinn mehr macht, diesen Krieg anzufangen. Aber ich würde nicht sagen, dass es extra entwickelt worden ist.
Aber so sagen, das war bei der Atombombe, war das ja sozusagen das, was passiert ist. Aber diese Idee existiert anscheinend schon vorher. Also auch bei der Maschinengewehr entwickelt hat sich gedacht, okay, diese Waffe ist so schrecklich, die wird einfach keiner mehr einsetzen, weil sie so fürchterlich ist. Und dann haben wir keinen Krieg mehr.
Es gibt ein paar interessante Details. Zum Beispiel gibt es in den Zeichnungen von Leonardo, der viele Kriegsmaschinen designt hat, der hat immer, also ich glaube, ein oder zwei Fälle, wo es sogar richtig gezeigt, in denen Leute Sachen nachgebaut haben, wird immer Sachen weggelassen da drin oder falsch gemacht. Also der hat halt irgendwie so Fehler eingebaut, die man nur korrigieren konnte, wenn man die Maschine verstanden hat. So kann man sagen, okay, falls seine Zeichnung verloren geht, dass sie nicht in falsche Hände fällt. Oder eben, dass klar ist, dass man ihn dazu braucht, um das zu machen, so Job Security technisch. Das erinnert mich immer so ein bisschen daran, wenn früher Hacker Exploit Code released haben, also halt Software, um Dinge aufzumachen, dann war es eigentlich ziemlich lange üblich, also vor Metasploit, bevor es automatische Export Frameworks gab, da halt Fehler einzubauen. Also, dass man halt released hat den Code, wo man sieht, was das Problem ist und wie man es halt irgendwie angeht, aber dass der Code, um es auszunutzen, halt nicht funktionierte. Sondern halt irgendwie so, ja, da irgendwie hier und da eine Kleinigkeit falsch war und man halt wirklich verstehen musste, was man tat, um es halt irgendwie zum Funktionieren zu bringen. Ob man jetzt daraus rekonstruieren kann, dass die halt irgendwie ein schlechtes Gewissen hatten da, wäre ein bisschen weiter geholt, glaube ich. Aber interessant finde ich also dieses Detail, dieses Waffen aus Wissen, also was sich ja durch die Zeit zieht, dass schon damals die offenbar intensiv darüber nachgedacht haben, wie sie halt dieses Wissen, keine Ahnung, containen können oder halt irgendwie im Zaum halten können.
Na, bei den Bombenmauernleitungen, die es bei MacGyver gab, da sind ja auch immer gerade der entscheidende Teil da zurückgehalten worden.
Hast du mal nachverzogen?
Hast du aus dem Kaugummi in der Büroklammer versucht, eine Bombe? Okay. Jetzt gibt es eine andere Idee, die könnte man vielleicht bekommen, wenn man so denkt, Leute bauen was. Das ist eine Idee, die Rainer anscheinend auch sehr schnell hatte, als die Sendung losging, weil er hat angerufen und wollte sie hier kurz präsentieren. Guten Abend, Rainer.
Grüß dich, Nand. Eine Sache noch von einem, der vorreden hat, geschichtig mit dem Kanonenbau. Die größte Kanone der Welt ist in der Geschichte gebaut worden, um Konstantin Opel zu erobern. Das andere ist, dass bei den Soldaten 10 bis 30 Jahre Schweigepflicht existiert und leider die größten Teil der Forschungsgelder auch in die Militärforschung gehen. Meiner Ansicht nach sind die Drohnen ja auch nur ein Teil der technischen Entwicklung, der Vernichtungsmaschinen. Bei den Drohnen ist es so von den Veröffentlichungen her, dass die angeblich sehr präzise zielen und vernichten sollen. Und auf der anderen Seite ist die bei Drohnen einsetzen, ist die Zahl der zivilen Todesopfer ansteigend.
Reiner, dazu wollen wir in der Sendung noch kommen.
Gut, dann von der Entwicklung her bin ich der Meinung, durch Internetrecherche, dass die Militärs eigentlich schon lange selbst autonome agierende Roboter haben müssten. Der Hintergrund ist, von dem Gotthard Günther, ist in Amerika in den 40er Jahren das Programm oder die Grundlagen, das Gehirn erstellt worden. Und durch, glaube ich, einen Artikel in der SHIP gab es mal eine Zeitleiste, wie die militärische Entwicklung ist. Und da ist Ende 68 von dem Militär ans MIT ein Auftrag ergeben worden, Transportmaschinen für Menschen entwickeln zu lassen. Und diese Spinnen-Fortbewegungsmöglichkeiten technisch oder aber diese Rohrraupen um Verstoff...
Rainer, du bist ein bisschen schnell. Die Frage ist sozusagen, und ich dachte, darüber willst du sprechen...
Technischer Stand bei autonomen Robotern, ja.
Findest du das eine gute Idee, dass man eine Roboter dafür nimmt?
Da ist, würde ich sagen, eine Fehlentwicklung. Weil generell sollte der Fortschritt, deshalb erwähnte ich das mit den Forschungsgeldern zum größten Teil in die Militärforschung, sollte nicht zur Vernichtung in keine Art von irgendwelcher Waffe gesteckt werden, sondern sollte für die friedliche Entwicklung der Technik und für die menschliche Kommunikation und zueinander oder füreinander entwickelt werden. Und nicht um Menschen zu vernichten und Kriege zu führen, wo die größte Teil der Technik immer mehr Zivilisten tötet.
Das wäre in der Tat natürlich eine schicke Idee, aber die lässt sich ja nicht umsetzen. Jetzt also anscheinend, was ich mich jetzt frage, und die Frage geht es wieder sagen an die Leute hier im Studio, die Idee könnte doch eigentlich sein, dass man sagt, okay, wir haben jetzt, also die Wissenschaft könnte auch auf die Idee gekommen sein, wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit versucht, möglichst effektive Vernichtungsmaschinen zu erstellen, um so ein Abschreckungspotenzial zu haben. Das hat nicht funktioniert. Gleichzeitig, Rainer sagt auch so, Krieg ist doof. Könnte man nicht den Krieg einfach von den Maschinen führen lassen?
Diese Idee gibt es in der Science Fiction schon länger. Dass man sagt, man entwickelt die Drohnen oder Kriegsroboter so lange weiter, bis man sie einfach irgendwo aussetzen kann auf einem Schlachtfeld oder Spielfeld. Und lässt sie dann halt mal da machen. Und wer am Ende gewonnen hat, hat halt gewonnen. Die interessante Frage ist, wer würde sich denn daran halten, dass man jetzt verloren hat? Wenn man tatsächlich nicht physisch besiegt ist oder so. Und die zweite Frage ist, gibt es überhaupt sowas wie besiegt gerade noch? Also wenn wir uns halt die Kriege angucken der letzten Jahre, denn was halt immer seltener wird, ist, dass es halt sowas wie einen Sieg gibt. Also dass es halt irgendeine Art von Entscheidungen gibt, dass dann halt Schluss ist, dass jetzt irgendwie der Krieg vorbei ist. Und die einzigen Wege, wie solche Kriege in der Regel heute beendet werden, ist halt, indem es halt irgendeine Art von politischen Übereinkommen gibt, dass irgendwie alle Seiten an der Macht beteiligt werden und halt irgendjemand zufällig Öl findet und alle genug Geld haben. Und gut häufig ist dann der Ölfond irgendwie nur der Einstieg in den nächsten Krieg, weil dann wieder irgendjemand kommt, der was von dem Öl abhaben will. So, also diese Frage des Krieges und der Art und Weise, wie Krieg geführt wird, die ist auch sehr essenziell eben genau für die Entwicklung von diesen Waffen, weil wir immer mehr ja keinen Krieg haben, sondern nur nicht Frieden. Also dass es halt keine Kriegserklärung mehr gibt, keine offenen Kampfhandlungen, sondern halt immer nur so verdeckte, verwurzelte Operationen.
Und genau darüber werden wir dann gleich sprechen. Also A, über die Art und Weise, wie diese Drohnen jetzt überhaupt entwickelt sind, dass man doch auf die Idee kommt, die selbstständig auf den Hand losgehen zu lassen. Aber auch darüber, wie sie den Krieg verändern oder nicht fliegen, wie Frank es gerade gesagt hat. Erdgeiste wurde es noch.
Na, ich wollte eigentlich noch mal ein bisschen ausholen und schauen, wie über die Jahre dieser Krieg eigentlich formalisiert worden ist. Auf eine Art und Weise, dass man irgendwann erkannt hat, dass man schließlich Menschen und auch seine eigenen Bürger losschickt und potenziell Verluste zu erleiden hat. Und auf der anderen Seite, dass es genauso geht, dass da so ab 1900 ein bisschen was auch nahe Regelwerke aufgebaut worden sind, um eine sichergebende Armee einfach dann nicht abzuschlachten. Dass es Genfer Konventionen gibt, die in der Theorie zumindest sagt, was passieren soll, nachdem sich Soldaten der Gegenseite ergeben haben, wie die zu behandeln sind. Dass dann natürlich Offiziere besser zu behandeln sind als normale Soldaten. Sprich das so ein bisschen aus dem Ständeverständnis der Zeit heraus. Aber dieses immer weiter formalisieren und dieses immer weiter durchspielen eines Kriegs, was ja dann vom Brettspiel-Schach so bis dann irgendwann in War Games, wo es dann in dem Film im Computer einfach alle Möglichkeiten ausgerechnet worden sind und er gesehen hat, dass es an der Stelle keinen Gewinner gibt, ist dieses formalisieren, dieses den Regeln unterwerfen, um dann wirklich nicht bis zum letzten Mann kämpfen zu müssen. Dann gibt es zum Zweiten Zeichen Weltkrieg hat sich das dann auch so entwickelt, dass dann in Deutschland dann einfach Parolen ausgegeben worden sind, wirklich Berlin bis zum Letzten zu verteidigen und dann eine verbrannte Erde zu hinterlassen, hat dann diese Traditionen dann wirklich einmal final beendet. Und danach wurden dann Kriege nur noch schlimmer.
Und du meinst sozusagen, das setzt sich dann mit der Entwicklung der Drohne und der Kriegsmachinerie dann auch noch weiter fort, also die weitere Entmenschlicherung oder Entregelung des Krieges?
Naja, der Grund, warum der Krieg geregelt wurde, also warum es halt sowas wie die Hagerland Kriegsordnung gibt und warum sowas wie das Rote Kreuz entstanden ist mit den dazugehörigen Gebräuchen, dass man sagt, okay, also man greift halt keine Krankenhäuser an oder man hat Leute mit einer Rot-Kreuz-Flagge da landlaufen, dann schießt man nicht auf die. Der war ja, dass die Kriege halt eben immer krasser wurden. Also dass halt eben mit dem Einzug von Maschinengewehren und von Schrabnelgranaten und eben der Industrialisierung des Krieges da halt unglaubliche Massaker passiert. Also wenn man sich so den ersten Weltkrieg anguckt, also der Einsatz von Chemiewaffen, diese monatelang Grabenkämpfe, wo niemand gewinnen konnte, weil quasi die Industrien der Länder gegeneinander kämpften, weil es halt nur noch darum ging, wer schaufelt schneller die Munition an die Front und wer hat noch genug Leute, die nicht demoralisiert sind, um die Maschinenwaffen zu bedienen. Und daraus resultierte ja dann halt eben so eine Art Übereinkommen, was halt zum Beispiel dazu führt, dass im zweiten Weltkrieg Chemiewaffen in großen Stile eingesetzt wurden, außer in Asien. Und dass halt man versuchte zumindest irgendeine Art von Umgangsweise einzuhalten. Und halt natürlich Kriegsverbrechen in riesigen Mengen passieren. Und auch eine Menge bewusste Verstöße gegen diese Regeln da waren. Aber überhaupt war man sich dessen bewusst, dass man gegen eine Regel verstößt. Und der Schritt, der dann aber passiert ist, zum Beispiel beim Vietnamkrieg, war, dass man sich drum rum argumentiert hat. Dass man bewusst gesagt hat, okay, jetzt dieses Dorf da auszurotten, hat dann halt nichts mehr mit Krieg zu tun, sondern das nennt man dann halt irgendwie Counterinsurgency, also Aufstandsbekämpfung.
Okay, und da gibt es dann zumindest ein Bewusstsein hat sich da auch entwickelt für die Sachen, die da passieren. Und weil man jetzt sozusagen über Drohnenberichterstattung, weil man das sieht dann immer so präzise Schläge, da müssen nur die Leute dran glauben, die bösen Terroristen und so. Und wir klären jetzt gleich mal, was diese Drohnen jetzt eigentlich genau sind, wie die funktionieren, was die bieten, was Leute damit machen, wer dahinter steckt und dann natürlich auch sozusagen, wie das dieses ganze Geschehen verändert und ob das wirklich diese Präzision und diese Sauberkeit hat, die da mal angepräsent wird. Vorher machen wir aber das Fritz-Info im Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr und danach geht's gleich weiter.
Es kommt dramatisch schnell auf uns zu. Genau. Mitten in der Fritz Tram. Mitten im Berliner Straßenbahnnetz. Und das geht so. Wir fahren mit unserer Fritz Tram durch Berlin. Lassen die Orsons darin ein Konzert spielen. Und mit euch zusammen wird das ganze dann Straßenbahnbrechend voll. Und gut. Das allererste Fritz Tram Konzert.
Auf die Schiene gebracht mit freundlicher Unterstützung der BVG.
Und wenn ihr da dabei sein wollt, dann achtet ab komm'nem Montag auf die Fritz Tram im Radio. Nächster Halt, Fritz-Tram-Konzert. Wenn ihr die hört, sofort bei uns anrufen. Und mit ein bisschen Glück seid ihr am 5. November dabei beim allerersten Fritz-Tramp-Konzert. Mit die Ossens.
Ich bin Banksy.
Und mit ein bisschen Glück auch mit euch.
Und das hört man um kurze halb elf. Mit Falko Wittich.
Nach der Prügelattacke am Berliner Alexanderplatz sind zwei Tatverdächtige wieder auf freiem Fuß. Laut Staatsanwaltschaft kam ein gestern festgenommener 19-Jähriger wieder frei. Gegen einen 21-Jährigen erging zwar Haftbefehl, dieser wurde aber außer Vollzug gesetzt. Weiter in Untersuchungshaft sitzt ein 19-Jähriger, der am Dienstag festgenommen wurde. Die jungen Männer gehören zu einer Gruppe, die für den Tod eines 20-Jährigen verantwortlich gemacht werden. Sie sollen ihr Opfer beim Alexanderplatz vor 11 Tagen so brutal zusammengeschlagen haben, dass der 20-Jährige später starb. Die syrische Armee will für die Zeit des islamischen Opferfests alle Militäreinsätze einstellen. Die Waffenruhe solle gemäß dem Vorschlag des UN-Sondergesandten Brahimi von Freitagmorgen bis zum Ende der Feiern am Montag gelten, teilte das Militär mit. Die freie syrische Armee, der die meisten Rebellen angehören, erklärte kurz darauf, sie wolle sich ebenfalls an den Waffenstillstand halten. UN-Generalsekretär Ban forderte Armee und Aufständische in Syrien auf, die Feuerpause tatsächlich einzuhalten. Der Berlin-Marathon für nächstes Jahr ist ausverkauft. Laut Pressesprecher waren alle 40.000 Plätze nach nur dreieinhalb Stunden vergeben. Ein neuer Rekord. Im vergangenen Jahr hatte es rund sechs Wochen gedauert, bis alle Startplätze weg waren. Der Berlin-Marathon findet nächstes Jahr, findet nächstes Jahr am 29. September statt. Start! In der Fußball Europa legte hat Bayer Leverkusen 14-0 bei Rapid Wien gewonnen. Hannover kam in Schweden zu einem 2-1 Erfolg gegen Helsingborg. Im Moment da spielt Mönchengladbach gegen Olympique Marseille. Wir sind 20 Minuten vor Schluss und Gladbach führt aktuell mit 2-0. Und außerdem spielt auch Stuttgart. Und zwischen Stuttgart und Kopenhagen, da steht es 20 Minuten vor Schluss, noch 0-0.
Wetter!
Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen, wir haben derzeit in Berlin 7°C in Pankow, 8°C in Steglitz-Angermünde und Neuropin 7°C, Potsdam-Kotbus, Frankfurt und Wittenberge 8°C. In der Nacht weniger Wolken, es bleibt meist trocken. Tiefstwerte liegen zwischen plus 3 und minus 1°C. Am Tage dann im Südenteils wolkig, sonst heiter und meist trocken, das bei maximal 5-8°C. Stadtverkehr Berlin, 100 Stadtring Richtung Neukölln-Treptow. Da haben wir teilweise Stau oder stockenden Verkehr derzeit. Die A111 statt Autobahn, statt einwärts bis morgen früh 5 Uhr. Vollsperrung zwischen Weidmanns-Lusterdam und am Festplatz. Gegen Mitternacht beginnt die Sperrung bereits an der Schulzendorfer Straße. Grund sind hier Wartungsarbeiten. Marzahn, die Hellersdorfer Straße, die ist statt auswärts gesperrt zwischen alter Hellersdorfer Straße und Riesaerstraße. Grund ist ein Unfall, hier kann es sich stauen. In Mitte, da gibt es Filmarbeiten heute Nacht. Die Kronenstraße, die ist dicht zwischen Glinkerstraße und Charlottenstraße. In beiden Richtungen noch bis 6 Uhr. Und zum Schluss zur S-Bahn. Wegen einer Signalstörung in Pankow-Heinersdorf kommt es auf den Linien S1, S2 und S8 zu Verspätungen und Teilausfällen. Die Linie S8, die verkehrt derzeit nur zwischen Zäuten, Grünau und Greifsweider Straße. Gute Fahrt!
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon. Zu Gast sind vom Chaos Computer Club Erdgeist und Frank Rieger und außerdem ist noch hinter den Kulissen Rob mit dabei. Es geht um Kriegsmaschinerie. Wir haben jetzt gerade in der ersten halben Stunde kurz zusammengefasst eine Historie dessen, wie Nerds, Militärs zur Hand gegangen sind gemacht und wollen jetzt zur Jetztzeit kommen und zu dem Thema, das sozusagen der eigentliche Aufhänger ist, nämlich die sogenannten Drohnen. Habt ihr vielleicht mitbekommen, sind im Nahen Osten sozusagen mehr oder weniger eingesetzt worden und sind unbemannte Flugzeuge, um es ganz kurz zu sagen. Und die sind halt für Überwachung und für Tötung verwendet worden. Und was da dahinter steckt an Technik und was das Ganze dann aus dem macht, was wir kriegen. Das wollen wir jetzt hier klären. Genau. Und den Anfang würde ich machen, zu sagen, mit etwas, was vielleicht jeder kennt oder zumindest schon mal gesehen hat. Es gibt diese Quadrokopter oder Hexakopter oder Oktokopter, kleine Dinger, die so irgendwie fünf, vier bis acht Propelloren haben und sich allein in der Luft halten können, wo man auch eine Kamera dranhängen kann und die immer mal wieder für Aufsehen gesorgt haben. Zum Beispiel beim Chaos Communication Congress werden die immer regelmäßig auch vorgeführt, dann fliegen die mit bunten Lichtern durch die Nacht. Und aus Russland hat man im letzten Jahr das mal gesehen, da wurden Demonstrationen von Demonstranten überwacht, damit man mal sehen konnte, wie viele da sind. Das ist die Frage, ist das jetzt wirklich, das nennen wir auch Drohne, kann man auch für ein paar hundert Euro kaufen, zum selber mit rumspielen, ist das sozusagen auch das, was das meditär hat oder ist das was anderes? Also was genau sind denn jetzt eigentlich diese Drohnen, über die wir sprechen? Ist das überhaupt eine Kategorie oder ist das dann auch so, dass man sagt, aha, Drohnen, ja, da gibt es die und die und die und die?
Letzteres. Also es ist so, dass die Spannbreite reicht halt von dem, was wir aus dem Modellbau und Spielzeugbereich kennen und was halt so in der selben Größenklasse ist, also kleine Flugzeuge, die aus der Hand gestartet werden und so eine Dreiviertelstunde fliegen oder eine Viertelstunde fliegen, bis hin zu, sagen wir mal so, die Oberklasse, sind dann halt so was wie die Global Hawk, die 48 Stunden in der Luft bleiben und so was wie 20 Kilometer hoch fliegen und also quasi um den ganzen Planeten fliegen können, vollständig autonom und mit entsprechenden Kameras und Antennen und Radars ausgerüstet sind und dazwischen reicht halt so die Spannbreite.
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich sozusagen nicht von heute auf morgen gekommen. Wo kommt das her? Hat da irgendjemand gedacht, lasst uns mal die Piloten aus den Flugzeugen nehmen?
Angefangen hat das Ganze tatsächlich mit einem Bedürfnis danach, dass man Leute trainiert, die Flugabwehrkanonen bedienen. Also wenn du halt so Leute, so Flaggkanonen hast und musst du die irgendwie trainieren. Und wenn die immer auf richtige Flugzeuge schießen, das ist dann halt irgendwann ein bisschen teuer. Weil manchmal treffen die dann auch, selbst wenn halt nur ein geschlepptes Ziel benutzt wird. Und dann gab es halt die Idee, man nimmt einfach Modellflugzeuge, die auch damals ja schon radikontrollierbar waren, also per Funk. Und hat die halt an großen Stückzahlen gebaut, also einige Zehntausend so im Laufe des Zweiten Weltkriegs. Und irgendwann hat man da halt angefangen, dann halt Fotoapparate einzubauen oder Kameras einzubauen oder auch einfach Sprengstoff einzubauen, die als Marschleckörper zu verwenden. Und solche Entwicklungen gab es eigentlich auf allen Seiten, so ging in dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Und danach ging die Entwicklung relativ kontinuierlich weiter. Also auch während des Kalten Krieges wurden ziemlich wahnsinnige Projekte gemacht, also Überschaltdrohnen, die dann in wenigen Stunden China überqueren konnten und Fotos machen konnten. Und dann gab es so richtig wahnsinnige Projekte, wo die Amerikaner überlegt haben, eine Drohne zu bauen, die 32 Atombomben über der Sowjetunion abwerfen kann und mithilfe eines offenen Atomreaktors betrieben wird. Wo halt nicht, weil es eine Drohne ist, muss man halt nicht abschirmen, sondern lässt das Ding halt einfach so fliegen. Also die Idee, den Piloten wegzulassen, die gibt es halt schon sehr lange, aber jetzt erst so in den letzten 15 Jahren etwa, ist es so, dass die Technologie soweit ist, dass man es auch wirklich ökonomisch machen kann. Also dass halt die Sensoren soweit sind, die GPS da ist, also das Global Positioning System für die Lokalisierung da ist, dass die Computer schnell genug geworden sind und man halt auch Software hat und Qualitätssicherungsmechanismen, um dafür zu sorgen, dass so ne Dinger dann halt eben auch mal stunden- oder tageweisen in der Luft bleiben können, ohne kaputt zu gehen.
Das Problem ist, wenn du die Drohnen einfach immer fernsteuerst und nicht auch zwei, vier autonome Dinge erledigen lassen kannst, dann hat dein Feind die einfache Option, einfach solange das Signal zu jammen, bis die Drohne dann abstürzt oder so Dinge tut, für die sie dann programmiert worden ist, was im Zweifel einfach Notlandung einleitend ist. Und so, dass die brauchbare Drohnentechnologie wirklich erst, nachdem dort auch komplexere Aufgaben von der Drohne autark erledigt werden können, dann da am Computer der Drohne stattfinden.
Seit wann gibt es das denn?
Na, also die Entwicklungen fingen so an, die neueren Generationen aus Afghanistan und Irak, diese Predator-Klasse, die wurde während des Kosovo Krieges entwickelt. Also Ende der 90er. Da wurden zum ersten Mal Systeme gebaut, die über Satelliten kontrolliert werden konnten. Also wo halt nicht mehr du in Funk-Reichweite sein musst, sondern über den Satelliten arbeiten kannst. Und Satelliten, so Meteorschkommunikationen und Satelliten, sind in der Regel geostationär. Das heißt, bewegen sich in 36.000 km Entfernung von der Erde und haben dementsprechend auch relativ viel Verzögerung des Signals. Das heißt, man hat dann halt so was wie zwei Sekunden Verzögerung. Beim Steuern damit kann man halt nicht wirklich fliegen. Deswegen wurden dann halt Methoden entwickelt, dass man eine sogenannte Wegpunktsteuerung macht. Das heißt, man sagt, der Drohne fliegt dahin, fliegt dahin. Wenn du da bist, dann fliegt man im Kreis. Und da ist übrigens dein Ziel, und richte mal die Kamera dahin. Und so dass man eben durch ein abstraktes Erteilen von Aufgaben die Notwendigkeit der unmittelbaren Fernsteuerung, also des Stabilhaltens in der Luft zum Beispiel, also des Ausgleichens und Austarienz, dass man die dirigieren konnte.
Das kann man also sagen, das hätte ich dann schon seit Längerem, also seitdem quasi der Fall, dass die Drohne eigentlich allein fliegen kann und nur noch die Aufträge.
Genau, das ist so seit ungefähr zehn Jahren funktionsfähige Technologie. Bisschen mehr, so zwölf Jahre etwa.
Ist es, weil Erdges gerade meinte, Funk kann man ja irgendwie auch so stören. Gibt es mit Satellitenfunk dann trotzdem?
Ja, ein Satellitenfunk ist natürlich ein bisschen resistenter dagegen, aber kann natürlich auch gestört werden. Und das ist eben auch der Grund, warum das Militär jetzt immer mehr Autonomie haben möchte. Also, dass sie sagen, okay, wir wollen da direkt Algorithmen einbauen, die zum Beispiel Ziele selber finden.
Also das Endziel ist wirklich das Sagen des Militärs, also soweit man das von außen beurteilen kann, eine Drohne zu haben, die komplett alleine agieren kann.
Also dazu müssen wir vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen ausholen, wie Militär heutzutage funktioniert. Und eines der wesentlichen Dinge ist halt, dass die Zeit großer Landstreitkräfte mehr und mehr abgelöst wird durch diese Sondereinsatztruppen-Logik, die halt sagt, okay, wir verbinden halt Geheimdienst und Militär zu einer integrierten Einheit. Und, also gerade wird es diskutiert zum Beispiel, wie wurde Bin Laden gefunden? Ist halt eine Integration von Folterknechten, von Drohnen, von Geheimdiensten, von Special Forces-Truppenteilen, die in der Lage sind, auf Basis von Informationen sehr, sehr schnell zu handeln. Also die halt dann teilweise, was ist es nicht, wenn sie da so eine Hütte in Afghanistan oder Pakistan gestürmt haben, noch in die Luft die Daten auswerten, dann eine Drohne dahinschicken, wo sie sich einen Telefonadressbuch oder ein Telefon, was sie auswerten, finden daraus eine Telefonnummer, gucken, wo ist die Telefonnummer. Und noch während der Hubschrauber in der Luft ist, schicken sie da eine Drohne hin, um dieses Haus zu erwarten. Und wenn es irgendwie verdächtig ist, dann schießen sie halt gleich die Rakete drauf. So funktioniert heutzutage diese Kriegsführung. Das ist also einfach dieses Intelligence Driven War. Das ist das Stichwort dazu. Und darauf sind auch diese Drohnenkonzepte ausgerichtet. Die sind halt dafür gedacht, dass sie für lange Zeit große Landstriche beobachten können und da auch erkennen können, wie Muster funktionieren. Also wie sieht ein normaler Tagesablauf in so einer Stadt aus? Wo gehen die Leute hin? Wo kommen sie her? Was tun sie? Und was weicht davon ab? Also die Muster sind halt die Mustererkennung. Und zu erkennen, wenn Dinge anormal sind, da wird halt dran gearbeitet, den Computer beizubringen. Und dann das eben nicht mehr irgendwo stattfinden zu lassen, diese Analyse aus der Basis der Drohnen-Videofeeds, die über den Satellit nach Hause geblieben werden, sondern das möglichst in der Drohne stattfinden zu lassen, eben weil zum einen die Drohnen-Signale über den Satelliten gestört werden können, zum anderen weil die halt nicht genug Bandbreite haben. Also die haben halt einfach...
Kurze Frage, das ist jetzt noch Science-Fiction?
Nee.
Das ist schon...
Das ist das, woran sie gerade arbeiten. Was sie gerade tun, ist, die wollen der Drohnen mehr Autonomität geben und mehr Möglichkeit geben, selbst zu handeln, auf der Basis von immer gröberen Vorgaben. In der Militärhäute funktioniert das so, da gibt es die Rules of Engagement. Das heißt, da wird den Soldaten gesagt, ihr geht jetzt in diesen Einsatz, in dieses Land. Und hier sind die Regeln, nach denen ihr Waffengewalt anwenden dürft. Also nach denen ihr sagen dürft, wir schießen jetzt. Und die heißen halt so, keine Ahnung, nur wenn ihr selber beschossen werdet und nicht irgendwie wegrennen könnt. Oder die heißen halt, wenn einer eine Waffe trägt, darfst du ihn erschießen. Also diese Rules of Engagement, die versucht man mittlerweile in Algorithmen zu coden. Also man redet ja immer gerne von Roboterethik, also davon, wie man Robotern beibringt, sich nach Kriegsrecht zu verhalten. Und da hat man ja immer so ein bisschen den Asym auf dem Kopf. Also hier mit dem iRobot, den typischen drei Regeln der Robotik. Aber so militärische Robotik hat damit genau gar nichts zu tun. Also der robotische Roboter haben halt keine Regeln a la Selbstahealt oder halt von Menschenleben oder was auch immer, sondern haben halt Rules of Engagement. Also wenn sie dann autonom sind. Und das ist halt so der Punkt, an dem es dann halt anfängt echt ungemütlich zu werden, weil man eben nicht so weit geht, dass man sagt, der Roboter muss die Situation verstehen oder muss halt irgendwie in der Lage sein, halt algorithmisch zu erkennen, was das Problem ist. Sondern kann halt nach so kleinen, ausgewählten Schnipseln von okay, wer eine Waffe trägt, ist ein Feind vorgehen. Auch wenn, keine Ahnung, es halt irgendwie ein Jäger ist, der gerade um die Ecke kommt. Also dieses Erkennen ist der Computer immer noch nicht möglich. Und die Zielrichtung der derzeitigen Entwicklung ist ganz klar dahin, dass man sowohl in der Luft als auch zu lande, als auch auf dem Wasser möglichst das Thema haben will, den man nur noch so einfache Aufgaben gibt. Wo halt nicht mehr so eine komplexe, detaillierte Steuerung notwendig ist, dass man sagt, okay, dieses Haus da hinten, sondern sagt, okay, wer in der Gegend eine Waffe trägt, ist tot.
Okay, wie ist es denn derzeit, also derzeit ist es sagen, woran gearbeitet, wie ist denn derzeit die Steuerung? Gibt es dann sozusagen noch für jede Drohne einen Piloten? Oder steuert da ein Typ irgendwie 40 und guckt ab und zu mal auf den Bildschirm? Oder wie ist das?
Also die derzeit meist eingesetzten Systeme sind so, dass eine Crew, also die aus einem Piloten und einem Missionoperator besteht, eine Drohne steuert. Experimentiert wird gerade mit einem Vierer-System, also dass zwei oder drei Leute vier Drohnen steuern, die dann eben entsprechend abstraktere Aufgaben bekommen, wenn man die halt eben entsprechend überwacht. Sie probieren auch andere Sachen aus, also dass sie halt zum Beispiel die Missionoperator nicht mehr neben den Piloten sitzen lassen, sondern den Piloten sozusagen mehrere Drohnen überwachen lassen und die Missionoperator auf mehrere von diesen Drohnen, je nachdem wo die gerade sind, dann halt eben entsprechend zugreifen können, um da halt irgendwie Kameras zu steuern oder Raketen auszulösen. Die probieren halt einfach geradeaus, es ist halt noch nicht ganz klar, worauf es hinausläuft. Klar ist aber, sie wollen halt den Personaleinsatz reduzieren.
Jetzt, also hört sich das über einen Moment noch so an, okay, die Drohne ist sozusagen in der Luft und macht da Beobachtungen. Töten die nicht?
Ja, also die Amerikaner waren interessanterweise die ersten, die zweiten, die eigentlich für Beobachtung gedachte Drohne aufgerüstet haben. Die Ersten waren lustigerweise die Iraner, die im Krieg damals gegen den Irak, so eine relativ einfache Drohne, wie so ein bisschen kleiner Walz und Predator, da haben die halt so RPG-7, also Panzerfäuste, drunter geschnallt. Und haben damit halt so ein paar vereinzelte Angriffe geflogen. Die Amerikaner haben nach dem 11. September mit Hochdruck daran entwickelt, dass sie Raketen unter ihre Beobachtungsdrohnen geschnallt bekommen. Und die dann halt eben auch entsprechend zügig weiterentwickeln. Also die Entwicklung heutzutage ist so, dass es ein bisschen unklar ist, wie das Verhältnis von bewaffneten zu unbewaffneten großen Drohnen ist. Klar ist aber, dass die Bewaffnung zu immer kleineren Drohnen geht. Also es ist halt so, die kleinsten Raketen, die so für Drohnen entwickelt werden, wiegen 1, 8 Kilo, also halt eine ganz leichte kleine Rakete. Die hat halt so irgendwie die Dimension von so einer Cola-Flasche und ist trotzdem in der Lage, ein Auto zu vernichten. Mit dem Ziel eben auch relativ kleine Drohnen, also die jetzt nicht so groß sind wie so ein Predator, kann man sich so vorstellen, wie so ein Predator ist halt ungefähr so groß wie so ein großes Kleinflugzeug.
Okay, Meter, Autos, irgendwas, was man schon mal selber gesehen hat.
Du kannst da schon mal dann versuchen zu extrapolieren, dass du an einen Quattrocopter der heutigen Bauart, also deinem 4-500 Dollar zu kaufen, das kleines Quattrocopterchen, da wirst du erstmal keine Marsflugkörper unten dran hängen können und keine Panzerfäuste, weil so 1, 8 Kilo Grad dann auch nicht weggetragen wird.
Ja, aber so eine Drohne, wie musst du dir die vorstellen? So von der Größenordnung, wie so ein kleiner Bus? Oder wie groß sind diese Teile?
Noch ein bisschen kleiner als die Kleinen. Also halb so groß.
Limousine quasi. Okay.
Und fliegen.
Und fliegen. Und fliegen die ganze Zeit im Kreis. Und wenn du dir das so vorstellen willst, wie das so in den Zentren aussieht, da sitzen halt nicht Leute direkt mit Joysticks, die dann so die Flugbewegungen kontrollieren, sondern die haben da so Interfaces, auf denen sie dann so sich Ziele auswählen und dann halt mal erst mal drauf, erst mal mit der Kamera und später, wenn ich auslöse, dann auch noch mit der Waffe. Dann der Unterschied zwischen, ob ich jetzt damit nur eine Drohne oder Enddrohnen in einem Team kontrolliere, ist dann halt nicht mehr so groß. Also da fliegen halt ein paar Drohnen, die haben irgendwie alle dieselbe Aufgabe, was ja so ein bisschen Redundanz gar nicht so schlecht ist. Ist es dann einfach total egal, wie viele ein einzelner Operator kontrolliert?
Also immer so die Dimensionen anzugeben. So eine Predator, was die momentan meist bewaffnete Drohne ist, die hat so was wie 14 bis 15 Meter oder 16 Meter Flügelspannweite. Und wiegt so was wie, beladen ungefähr eine Tonne, also mit allem drum und dran, also mit Raketen und Treibstoff, und ist so acht Meter lang.
Das sind also schon kleine Flugzeuge, das sind nicht sozusagen die Killer-Roboter, die irgendwie Miniatur durchs Fenster krabbeln, sind da noch nicht so mit dabei.
Genau, aber da hängen halt eben doch so sechs Raketen drunter oder so.
Und weil wir jetzt gerade von dem, wer wählt dieses Ziel, habt ihr gerade gesagt, wird vom Operator ausgewählt oder vom Piloten, ist nicht ganz klar geworden. Trifft ihr jetzt die Entscheidung, feuere auf dieses Ziel oder sagt der, der Drohne entscheidet du mal, wann du feuerst und auf wen?
Nee, also der momentane Status quo ist immer noch, dass der Mensch immer noch in the Loop ist. Also dass die Tötungsentscheidung vom Menschen getroffen wird. Und die Frage ist halt, aufgrund welcher Kriterien, also wie trifft der Mensch seine Entscheidung, der Drohne den Feuerbefehl zu geben. Und da gibt es halt verschiedene Dinge. Es gibt halt, also wenn wir zum Beispiel das amerikanische Militär nehmen, die haben halt eben diese Rules of Engagement, die halt sagen, unter diesen Bedingungen können wir schießen, die so ein bisschen formalisiert sind. Also die halt sagen, so okay, also wir müssen halt wenigstens bewaffnet sein und irgendwie nicht zu viele Schulkinder nehmen dran und so. Dann gibt es halt noch die Rules of Engagement des CIA, der auch eine eigene Drohnenflotte hat, die also genauso bewaffnet sind. Nicht von Militärpiloten geflogen werden, sondern von einfacher ausgebildeten Drohnenpiloten. Und die sind anders, also diese Regeln. Da ist es halt so, zum Beispiel halt jetzt so bei, wenn sie halt irgendwelche Terroristen beschießen, dann fällt halt häufiger Obama selber oder der CIA-Chef die Entscheidung.
Das sind nicht irgendwelche Terroristen, das ist meistens so die rechte oder linke Hand von Bin Laden, die da beschossen wird.
Ist immer die linke Hand von Bin Laden, ja, ist klar. Oder Bin Laden selber. Und die interessante Geschichte dabei ist, wie wird denn so ein Ziel ausgewählt. Und aus Pakistan ist zum Beispiel bekannt, dass die CIA dann Informanten am Boden halt so Klunken gegeben hat, die halt aussehen wie Steine. Aber da ist ein Infrarotsender drin, der halt ein gepulstes Infrarotsignal schickt. Und dann sagen sie, wenn du da den fiesen Terroristen hast, dann leg mal den Stein neben das Haus. Und dann wird dann daraus in dem CIA-Bericht eine zuverlässige Quelle auf den Boden, die halt irgendwie ein terroristisches Hauptquartier identifiziert hat und dann heldenhaft da den Stein hingelegt hat. Und in diversen Fällen, die mittlerweile auch dokumentiert sind, kam es dann halt vor, dass hinterher rauskam, naja, das war halt irgendwie der Haus von dem Nachbarn, der den Eselböser angeguckt hat, den sie dann halt zum Terroristen deklariert haben. Und dann halt den Schorch mit der Drohne ermordet haben. Und diese Art und Weise des Vorgehens, die halt doch relativ hemsarmlich und relativ wenig formal ist, die wird halt natürlich durch die Technologie erleichtert. Weil du halt einfach extrem weit weg bist, du siehst halt nur durch ein Kamerabild und hast halt keine ernsthafte, unmittelbare Beziehung mehr dazu.
Also alle Beteiligten, die es sagen, sind so indirekt, also der eine Typ hat halt nur den Stein hingelegt, der andere hat halt nur dem Piloten gesagt, dass er vielleicht mal da und so weiter. Also es gibt keiner mehr, der direkt abdrückt.
Genau, sie versuchen halt schon noch diesen Punkt, dieses Aufrechterhalten, dass der Mensch diese Entscheidung treffen muss, nach außen darzustellen. Also sie sagen, okay, wir nehmen es so wichtig, dass sogar der Präsident entscheidet, ob wir diesen Terroristen jetzt da töten dürfen bzw. ob wir da hinschießen dürfen. Aber die Realität scheint tatsächlich eine andere zu sein.
Für mich hört es sich so an, als ob jeder entweder sagen kann, ich hab ja nur dem und dem gesagt. Und irgendwann sagt einer, auf dem Bildschirm saß er aus und deswegen hab ich geklickt.
Dieses sich entfernen von da, wo dann am Ende ein Schaden entsteht, ist ja seit dem ersten Mörser geschossen. Man ist halt nicht mehr selber... Da hat mein anderer Mörserkollege den ausgerichtet und ich hab am Ende nur die Mörsergranate reinfallen lassen. Und vorne ist ja noch der Melde, der dafür gesorgt hat, also dass man sich da selber aus der Verantwortung zu stehlen versucht, ist ja nur auch nicht neu.
Aber hat das nicht sozusagen eine neue Qualität?
Ja, aber weiß nicht. Der Nachbar, der jetzt irgendwie so seinem Nachbar den Stein reinlegt, der ist da vielleicht schon noch eher dabei. Er setzt da nämlich schon bewusst die Tötungsmaschinerie in Gang. Und derjenige, der dann einfach nur das System aufgesetzt hat, der ist wirklich nur das Werkzeug zur Verfügung gestellt.
Na ja klar, kann ja jeder für sich sagen. Jetzt haben wir, also wenn ihr sprecht, fällt es immer sozusagen CIA und Obama und so. Wie sieht das denn in Deutschland aus? Gibt es in Deutschland keine Drohnen?
Also die Bundeswehr hat tatsächlich eigene Drohnen. Es gibt auch deutsche Drohnenhersteller. Also die wichtigsten sind so Kraus Mafai und Amt Pentsberg, sind so zwei von den großen. Die EADS, also Airbus, baut auch an Drohnen. Die Bundeswehr hat eine ganze Reihe von verschiedenen Drohnen im Einsatz. Also von so relativ kleinen Modellflugzeuggroßen Dingern, die zum Beispiel Mikado heißen über eine Drohne, die so ein bisschen so groß wie so eine kleine Chessner ist. Die heißt Luna. Und sie haben mehrere israelische Heron-1-Drohnen geleast. Man kann solche Drohnen auch liesen, wie man Flugzeuge liest.
Man semi-autonomes Militärgerät von fremden Leuten?
Von Israel ist in diesem Fall, ja. Und bildet halt Piloten daran aus. Und der Verteidigungsminister Demesia hat neulich relativ energisch gefordert, dass wir jetzt also auch bewaffnete Drohnen brauchen.
Haben wir also noch nicht?
Nee, haben wir noch nicht derzeit. Also es gibt eine Wunschbeschaffung von einem System, was sozusagen eine Einwegdrohne ist. Das ist halt eine Drohne, die fliegt da halt eine Zeit lang rum, also viele Stunden, bis sie halt ein Ziel identifiziert. Zum Beispiel auf der Basis einer Fahrzeug-Signatur oder einer Funksignatur. Also sie sagt, okay, da fährt ein Panzer oder da kommt dieses und jenes Funksignal, was zum Beispiel auch ein Mobiltelefonsignal sein kann, her. Und fängt dann halt schon mal an, in die Richtung zu fliegen und wartet dann noch auf das finale Einsatzsignal von einem Menschen. Interessanterweise hat dieses Projekt angefangen, als ein tatsächlich vollautonomes Projekt. Also wo gesagt wurde, okay, wir wollen diese Dinge haben, um zum Beispiel es in Kreisen zu lassen, zum Beispiel über Serbien oder wo auch immer der letzte Krieg war. Und wenn dann jemand seinen Panzer aus der Garage fährt, dann fliegt die Drohne halt dahin und macht bumm. Und das wurde dann abgebrochen und sie haben es halt ersetzt durch ein Projekt, wo eben noch der Mensch am Ende noch in der Loop ist. Und diese Drohne ist ziemlich klein. Also die hat heute glaube ich nur 1, 80 lang oder so. Also es ist halt eine relativ kleine, kompakte Angelegenheit. Das Kennzeichen ist eben, dass es halt versucht wird, in immer mehr verschiedenen Größen- und Einsatzszenarien unterzubringen. Zum Beispiel auch bei der Polizei.
Drohnen im Inneren?
Drohnen im Inneren, ja. Also in Deutschland werden von verschiedenen Landespolizeien so große Quadrocopter eingesetzt.
Für Überwachung dann aber?
Für Überwachungszwecke, genau. Noch nicht mit Raketen? Nee, diese Raketen zählen in Deutschland nicht zu zulässigen Polizeieinsatzmitteln.
Könnte fast Kriegswaffe dazu sagen.
Was die versuchen, sind halt ihre Kosten für Hubschrauber-Einsätze runterzukriegen. Wo wir jetzt passend in das Lied spielen könnten?
Das war aber nicht da, aber trotzdem müssten wir so ergänzen. Denke, wir wollten in eurem Kopf spielen vor jedem Hubschrauber-Einsatz. Wir haben es zu spät erfahren. Ich möchte mich an dieser Stelle rausreden. Genau, kurzer Break und dann geht es hier weiter im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon über Drohnen und andere Kriegsmaschinerie. Die zwei Sprechstunden. Hardline von AX Music, das Netlabel dazu heißt Brennnessel.pl. Das könnt ihr alle mal besuchen und den Song runterladen, weil Brennnessel ist sehr lange sehr still gewesen. Und wenn ihr ein paar Klicks kriegen, dann denken sie vielleicht, hey, wir könnten mal wieder coole neue Musik rausbringen. Das würde mich zumindest freuen. Ihr seid im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon. Es geht um Kriegsmaschinerie. Wir hatten einen kurzen historischen Abriss darüber, wie Nords Militärs und die Arme greifen. Wir haben jetzt die letzte halbe Stunde erklärt, was Drohnen eigentlich sind. Und jetzt tauchte während des Songs gerade die Frage auf, dass wir noch gar nicht erklärt haben, warum Drohnen eigentlich Drohnen heißen. Warum denn? Erdgeist, Frank Rieger von Chaos Computer Club, warum heißen Drohnen Drohnen?
Darüber gibt es mehrere Geschichten, aber die glaubwürdigste ist, dass einer der ersten Flugzeuge, aus denen eine Drohne gebaut wurde, die hieß halt B. Und daraus wurde dann halt die Fire B. Das war ein Zielsystem, also ein Zielsimulationssystem. Und irgendwann kam auf die Idee, naja, wenn es vorher Queen hieß, dann ist die andere Biene dann halt die Drohne.
Die, die man auch wegwerfen kann, die jetzt nur einen Zweck hat.
Genau, die halt nur eine begrenzte Nutzbarkeit hat. Und dann hat sich dieser Begriff Drohne etabliert. Im militärischen Jargon gibt es dann natürlich andere Abkürzungen. Also die fachlich korrekte Bezeichnung ist Unmanned Aerial Vehicle oder Unmanned Aerial Combat Vehicle. Das Combat steht dann dafür, dass es bewaffnet ist.
Da wollte ich gerade fragen, wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit von Drohnen, also sagen von schon semi-autonom agierenden Kriegsmaschinen geredet, die in der Luft sind. Gibt es nur da Drohnen? Oder gibt es, man könnte sich ja vorstellen, es gab ja auch mal die Legende vom Delfin mit der Sprenggranate, also gibt es auch Unterwasserdrohnen oder Landdrohnen, also Kriegsroboter auf eine andere Art und Weise?
Na es gab diverse Experimente, Tiere fernzusteuern, so auf Cockroaches, wie heißt es auf Kackalaken, haben sie ja auch schon Steuereinheiten drauf gebastelt, um sie dann so links, rechts lang wandern zu lassen. Das funktionierte schon ganz gut. Aber erst mit der Roboter-Technik und vor allem mit der Entwicklung von effizienter Batterietechnik ist jetzt das Entwicklung von wirklich autonomen Landrobotern auch realistischer geworden. Also die DARPA hat da erst vor ein paar Tagen einen neuen Challenge ausgeschrieben, wo sie zweibeinige Roboter einfach zur Verfügung gestellt haben. So ein paar grundsätzliche Routinen funktionieren. Jetzt baut mal daraus Software, die es schafft, einen bestimmten Hindernisparcours zu überwinden. Und dieser Hindernisparcours soll dann Fukushima darstellen, wo so ein Roboter durch die Gegend wandert, hat bestimmte Hindernisüberwindetüren aufmacht und ein Ventil zuschraubt und sich dann wieder daraus tut.
Das hört sich jetzt aber eher nach Supportaufgaben an. Also unterstützend und langsam, hat viel Zeit oder?
Naja, diese muss man vielleicht ein bisschen weiter auswählen. Diese DARPA Challenges sind für die Robotik relativ wichtig. Eine der bekannteren DARPA Challenges war die für autonomes Fahren. Also wo die DARPA gesagt hat, wir müssten noch langsam so weit sein, dass wir Technologie zusammen haben, Autos autonom fahren zu lassen. Die erste war halt ein relatives Desaster, wo halt die meisten Fahrzeuge nicht aus den Startboxen rauskamen. Und was am weitesten kam, kam so 35 Meilen oder so von den geplanten 200. Dann gab es halt zwei weitere Challenges. Am Ende von diesen Challenges fuhren Autos und zwar mehrere, völlig autonom durch eine simulierte Stadt ohne Unfälle zu bauen und haben da halt irgendwie Missionen erfüllt. Und die nächste DARPA Challenge ist halt ein bisschen anders, weil sie sagen, okay, es gibt einen komplizierten Teil dabei, nämlich die Hardware, die machen das selber. Die lassen sie bauen von einem Unternehmen namens Boston Dynamics. Da kann man mal googeln. Die bauen ziemlich abgefahrene Roboter. Also der eine ist der bekanntere davon, das ist der sogenannte Big Dog. Das ist halt so ein vierbeiniger Roboter, der stark so ein bisschen wie so ein Esel durch die Gegend und soll dazu dienen, Soldaten ihre Rucksäcke und Waffen und Munition hinterher zu tragen. Also dass sie die halt nicht selber schleppen müssen, wenn sie durchs Gelände herrschen. Und dann bauen die aber halt auch noch so ein System namens Cheetah, was halt so eine Robkatze ist. Und die sieht dann halt schon wesentlich mehr nach irgendwie Suchen und Töten aus. Also die kann sich halt auch sehr schnell bewegen. Also es rennt sehr schnell. Und sie bauen ein System namens Atlas. Und das ist halt genau dieser Roboter, von dem Edgar es gerade sprach, der für diese DARPA-Challenge verwendet wird. Die nächste DARPA-Challenge, da läuft jetzt gerade die Bewerbungsfrist, wo sich halt Teams bewerben können, darum, dass sie einen von diesen Robotern kriegen, um dann halt sich für diese Challenge die Software zu schreiben. Und da geht es halt darum, dass der Roboter sitzt in einem Raum, geht durch eine Tür aus diesem Raum heraus, kämpft sich durch eine teilweise eingefallene Trümmerwüste, bewegt sich zu einem Fahrzeug, fährt mit diesem Fahrzeug, also einem Traktor oder so, jedenfalls irgendwas, was offen ist, fährt mit diesem Traktor zu einem anderen Gebäude, kämpft sich da wieder durch ein Trümmerfeld zu einer Zielkoordinator und tauscht dann ein Ventil an einem Rohrsystem aus und fährt wieder zurück. Und zwar alles autonom, also ohne, dass sie mehr als die Zielkoordinaten vorgegeben werden, wohin sollen, was er tun soll. Und die rechnen natürlich wieder nicht damit, dass wir am ersten Mal durchkommen, aber zumindest werden wir danach, wenn diese LAPA-Challenges durch sind, Technologie haben mit zweibainigen Robotern, die in der Lage sind, solche Aufgaben zu erfüllen. Und das ist dann schon so verdammt nah an Terminate.
Ich will gerade sagen, wir reden jetzt seit einer Stunde darüber, deswegen hab ich natürlich sofort im Kopf, das Ventil könnte auch eine Handgranate sein.
Genau. Das ist halt so eines der grundlegenden Probleme der Roboterforschung, ist das Auseinanderhalten von so ziviler Forschung und militärisch erwendbarer Forschung ist halt quasi nicht möglich. Also gibt halt, naja, diese typischen zwei Disziplinen der Uni Roboterforschung, das eine ist der sogenannte Roboterfußball, also wo die Roboter halt Fußball spielen, wo man im Wesentlichen halt so Schwarmalgorithmen übt, also dass Roboter eng zusammenarbeiten können. Das andere ist das sogenannte Search and Rescue, was bedeutet, dass Roboter sich in unübersichtlichem Gelände bewegen und da drin Menschen finden, die da verletzt rumliegen oder auch irgendwelche Chemikraienfässer finden, die da irgendwie kaputt rumliegen und die markieren. Und wenn man sich das mal so kurz durch den Kopf gehen lässt, dann ist halt der Unterschied zwischen Search and Rescue und Search and Destroy marginal. Also ob man den Roboter ins Gelände schickt, um da Verletzte zu markieren, damit sie gerettet werden können, oder man ihn da reinschickt, um verborgene Gegner zu erschießen, der Unterschied ist nicht besonders groß. Und das macht eben doch dieses Problem, um mal sozusagen den Bogen so ein bisschen zurückzuspannen zum Eingangspunkt unserer Sendung, nämlich der Verantwortung des Wissenschaftlers, so kompliziert, dass man, wenn man in dem Bereich unterwegs ist und da forscht und entwickelt, dass man sich nie so richtig sicher sein kann, wofür seine Forschungsergebnisse jetzt eigentlich verwendet werden. Also zum Beispiel gerade diese Search-and-Rescue-Thematik, also die Algorithmen zum Beispiel, die benutzt werden, um zu erkennen, ob auf einem Infrarot-Kamera-Bild aus einer Drohne, ob da Menschen sind. Und was die jetzt gerade tun, lässt sich halt sehr vielfältig einsetzen. Kann man verwenden, um verschüttete Nervengebiete zu finden oder kann man verwenden, um illegale Grenzüberquerer zu identifizieren und zu erschießen oder abzufangen. Oder um zu beschließen, dass jetzt irgendwie diese fünf Leute da oben in den Bergen halt irgendwie Taliban sind, weil sie sich zufällig in der falschen Gegend befinden.
Wenn man sich jetzt die Diskussion um den sogenannten Hackerparagrafen anguckt, dann habt ihr ja gesagt, so eine Technologie ist erst mal nicht schuld, sondern das ist halt ein Werkzeug.
Wie seht ihr das in diesem Fall? Im Prinzip gilt es auch da. Man muss sich halt nur überlegen, wie hoch der Preis ist, den man halt willens ist, moragisch zu bezahlen. Dafür, wenn man seine geistige Energie in bestimmte Dinge steckt, wo die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie halt missbraucht werden können, möglicherweise höher ist als irgendwie der positive Nutzen, den man bei nicht missbräuchlicher oder nicht kriegerischer Verwendung erzielen kann. Und gerade in der Robotik ist diese Linie oft sehr fein und sehr, sehr schwer zu beantworten, weil man, wenn man nicht bösartig drüber nachdenkt, möglicherweise auch gar nicht drauf kommt, wie zum Beispiel halt so ein Mustererkennungsalgorithmus, den man vielleicht entwickelt hat oder so ein Greifalgorithmus oder so, wie der halt bösartig verwendet werden kann. Aber momentan ist es halt so, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass er bösartig verwendet wird, nahezu 100 Prozent ist, wenn es geht.
Das heißt, du würdest davon abraten, an sowas zu basteln oder?
Na, ich würde schon mir sehr genau überlegen, was ich da tue. Also ob es nicht möglicherweise zum einen Mittel und Wege gibt, solche Dinge so zu entwickeln, dass sie schwerer zu missbrauchen sind. Also unter anderem möglicherweise durch Lizenzen oder durch Eingrenzungen von Forschungsgebieten, dass man sagt, okay, also was wir an dieser Uni entwickeln, darf halt zum Beispiel nicht für kriegerische Zwecke verwendet werden. Das führt nicht dazu, dass Sachen nicht nachvollzogen oder nicht noch mal entwickelt werden, zumindest verzögert. Das ist vielleicht auch helfen kann. Und zum anderen denke ich mal, es ist auch durchaus eine Verantwortung, gerade der Akademiker, die in diesem Bereich unterwegs sind, sich an Maßnahmen zu internationalen Vertragswerken, zur Regulierung von solchen Systemen zu beteiligen, weil die haben die wissenschaftliche Kompetenz, um halt sagen zu können, an welchen Ecken macht es überhaupt Sinn, zum Beispiel mit Regulierung anzufangen? Oder wie kann man denn zum Beispiel versuchen, eine Verifikation aussehen zu lassen, indem man zum Beispiel sagt, okay, jede fliegende Drohne, die so rumfliegt, muss halt irgendwie eine eindeutige Kennung haben, von wem sie gehört und was sie da gerade tut und ähnliche Dinge.
Das könnte man natürlich total geschickt gleich zum nächsten Thema überleiten, nämlich die Drohneanonymisierung einer Waffe. Ich würde aber, bevor wir das machen wollen, erst mal festhalten, also der Wissenschaftler sollte möglicherweise diesmal nicht über der Turmarmast hinterher, sondern vorher drüber nachdenken, was da gebaut wird. Und ich habe jetzt auf der Liste, wo es um die Technik der Drohnen geht, um die Arten noch zwei Starkworte, Killboxes und Double Tap Strikes.
Na, Double Tap Strikes sind eigentlich nicht so richtig Technik, sondern eher eine Anwendung, die ziemlich perfide ist, gerade in den Gebieten Pakistan sind, denen die US-Amerikanischen oder wahrscheinlich US-Amerikanischen Drohnen eingesetzt werden. Die fliegen da Tag und Nacht und haben eine Strategie entwickelt, eine Rakete auf einen Punkt zu feuern, dort Verletzte und Tote zu verursachen. Und dann darauf zu warten, dass Helfer ankommen und dann noch mal zuzuschlagen, kurz danach, um generell das Einander-Helfen dort zu unterminieren.
Aber das erste Mal, als ich von so was gehört habe, war das glaube ich in Bali, wo es diesen Anschlag gab. Wo genau das auch passiert ist. Wo es ja gab einen Einschlag in der Stadt. Und dann irgendwie 20 Minuten später ist genau an dem Unglücksort oder an dem Anschlagsort noch mal eine riesige Bombe explodiert.
Das wurde auch im zweiten Weltkrieg verwendet, in dem Bomben mit unterschiedlich eingestellten Zeitzündern abgeworfen wurden. Also insbesondere die Briten haben sich da hervorgetan. Die haben bei den Bombenangriffen auf deutsche Städte gerne Zeitbomben verwendet, die halt so bis zu 48 Stunden später explodiert sind. Und haben sich teilweise auch angeguckt, wie lange es dauert, bis also Entwarnung gegeben wird. Bis die Leute aus den Bunkern kommen und anfangen aufzuräumen. Und dann die Zeitzünder auf diese Zeiträume eingestellt. Das Parfile an diesem Double Tap ist, was mit den Drohnen ist, dass es halt einen ähnlichen Effekt hat, wie diese Zeitbomben, die darauf abzielen, Feuerwehrleute und Krankenwagen zu erwischen. Weil es dazu führt, dass wenn ein Angriff passiert, wo eine Rakete einschlägt, dass die Leute spätestens nach dem zweiten oder dritten Mal nicht mehr trauen, um dahin zu gehen, den Verletzten zu helfen.
Und bei der Drohne hast du den Vorteil, du kannst halt gucken, wann er am meisten helfen wird. Du musst halt nicht die Uhr einstellen. Hat das noch was mit den Rules of Engagement zu tun?
Die Rules of Engagement werden schon eingehalten, weil die Rules of Engagement sagen, wer sich innerhalb dieses Gebietes befindet, also die sogenannte Killbox, gilt im Zweifel, wenn er tot ist, als Aufständischer.
Das musst du noch mal langsam erklären, wenn sie da schnallt.
Also der Punkt ist, man kann da so eine Drohne natürlich nicht so besonders viel sehen. Man kann halt erkennen, ob jemand irgendein Objekt trägt, was möglicherweise eine Waffe sein könnte oder ob er irgendwelche Dinge umlädt. Aber gerade wenn es nachts ist, dann hat man halt nur Infrarotbilder mit einer relativ beschränkten Auflösung. Und da Drohnen relativ hochfliegen, kann man halt nicht so genau sehen, was jetzt da eigentlich passiert. Du kannst es auf dem Boden und durch ein Nachtsichtgerät nicht wirklich sehen, was da wirklich passiert. Du kannst dann nur Indizien haben, wenn sie längere, kühlere Gegenstände umladen, also möglicherweise Waffen sein können. Also macht man Folgendes, insbesondere die Amerikaner haben halt definiert, dass wer immer männlich und über 14 ist und sich da, wo ein Raketenschlag oder sonstige Militäroperation befindet und dabei getötet oder verletzt wird, kann kein Zivilist sein, sondern muss offensichtlich ein Taliban gewesen sein oder ein sonstiger Al-Qaeda-Terrorist. Er war ja da als die Rakete einschluck und die Rakete wurde ja gegen Terroristen eingesetzt.
Das klingt auf eine sehr perfide Art und Weise logisch. Gibt es denn Berichte aus diesen Ländern?
Ja, da gibt es jetzt einiges an Berichten. Also der bekannteste Geschichte, die gerade auch ein bisschen durch die Medien ging, ist diese Living on a Drones-Studie, die von ein paar sehr renommierten amerikanischen Juristen durchgeführt wurde, die versucht haben, herauszukriegen, wie viele Zivilisten eigentlich zu Tode kommen und welche Auswirkungen hat denn das eigentlich, insbesondere in Pakistan. So andere Berichte, zum Beispiel aus Sudan oder aus Kolumbien, wo auch Drohnen eingesetzt wurden, sind halt ein bisschen sperrlicher. Was unter anderem auch daran liegt, dass die News-Coverage von da sowieso ein bisschen sperrlicher ist. Aber die Berichte aus Pakistan, wenn man die jetzt mal so als Beispiel nimmt, weil doch am meisten passiert, die sind halt schon sehr gruselig. Die gehen halt so weit, dass da ganze Dörfer verlassen werden, weil halt immer wieder was passiert. Und das halt so aus heiterem Himmel kommt. Die Drohnen fliegen halt so hoch und du hörst sie nur, wenn sie tiefer fliegen. Also wenn sie ganz oben an der Oberkante fliegen, hörst du sie halt nicht. Oder sie sind halt auch so weit weg, dass du sie nicht hörst. Und offensichtlich setzen die Amerikaner aber schon ein, dass sie Leute einschüchtern, indem sie halt einfach tiefer fliegen, sodass sie zu hören sind. Und ist dann so, dass in einigen von diesen Gebieten, also in Vaziristan, von halt so örtlichen Dorfbewohnern berichtet wird, dass sie ja so fünf, sechsmal am Tag halt Drohnen hören, weil die halt die ganze Zeit da unterwegs sind, und halt auch richtig viele sind. Und halt permanent was am Himmel ist, und du halt nicht weißt, ob es jetzt eine Drohne ist, die nur guckt, oder eine, die demnächst eine Rakete los schießt. Und das macht die Leute natürlich mürbelnd. Deswegen fliehen sie halt dann auch irgendwann aus den Gebieten.
Das heißt, das ist sozusagen nicht wirklich Kriegsführung, sondern werden quasi zivile Gebiete so als, ja, keine Ahnung. Warum sind gerade in dieser Region so viele Drohnen?
Na, weil die Amerikaner meinen, dass da irgendwie die Al-Qaeda bzw. die Taliban halt ihre Rückzugsräune haben und sich da halt trainieren und aufmunizieren.
Natürlich hinlaufen und Leute entsenden. Also Boots on the ground ist da echt anstrengend. Dort in den Bergen, in diesen Regionen, ist es echt schwer Nachschub hinzubekommen. Und die Locals kennen sich ja deutlich besser aus der Wunderseite mehreren hundert Jahren. Da ist so einmal Drohnen fliegen lassen in so einer Region, die naja, so in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung in der westlichen Welt eher so als, keine Ahnung, Ziegenhirten, keine Ahnung, da wären die Taliban schon die einzigen sein, die man so trifft, wenn man da mit den Drohnen hin und her fliegt. Da kann man halt mit der ganzen Technologie ausprobieren. Es ist gerade als Feind deklariert worden. Man möchte natürlich, es gibt Industrie, die einfach die Drohnen an den Mann bringen möchte. Und die brauchen natürlich immer wieder legitime Einsatzgebiete. Und wenn man dann in irgendeiner Region, wo die Pressecoverage eher gering ist, dann mal da rumspielen kann mit und schauen, wie das so alles funktioniert. Und ob man da auch wirklich in jedes Dorf reinkommt und wie man da vielleicht auch Crowdcontrol von so größeren Mengen Menschen da hinbekommt, dann ist es doch ein perfektes Einsatzgebiet für die Forschung.
Jetzt ist es ja bei allen anderen Waffen davor, dass man immer noch irgendwie sagen konnte, von wem die kommen. Also irgendwie große Bombenangriffe müssen von der Flugzeugflotte, die kommen halt irgendwo her. Selbst eine Atombombe, da gibt es halt nicht so viele. Da wusste man auch genau, wo die kommen. Natürlich in dem Krieg, wenn nicht jemand erschießt, weißt du auch im Zweifel, auch, weil das war. Oder wenn jemand erschossen wird, wenn du das gesehen hast. Jetzt ist es ja bei den Drohnen irgendwie nicht mehr so wirklich gegeben. Ihr redet immer von den Amerikanern. Weiß man wirklich, dass die Amerikaner sind, die die Drohnen haben? Also könnte nicht im Prinzip jeder, weil, naja, es ist halt Technik.
Obama hat sich da dann jetzt geoutet, nachdem er dann ganz stolz erklärt hat, dass er mithilfe der Drohnenflotte auch Osama bin Laden da erlegt hat, war das dann eigentlich auch schon ganz offiziell zugegeben, dass das wirkt. Wir können das und wir haben jetzt bewiesen, dass das auch sehr präzise funktioniert und damit ist schon ganz klar, dass die da zumindest unterwegs sind. Aber auf der anderen Seite hast du natürlich total recht, dass Technologie, die, wenn wir von leasing Drohnen reden, wenn wir von Hardware reden, die eh zu 99% aus China importiert wird, da kann man jetzt irgendwie nachgucken, findet immer dieselben Boards drauf, findet vielleicht Technologie, die irgendwo zusammengeschraubt wird und dann weiterverkauft an so alle Player, die da einfach nur noch Geld auf den Tisch legen, kannst du natürlich dir so als kleiner durchgeknallter Multimilliardär schon deine eigene Drohnenflotte aufbauen. Und am Ende ist selbst wenn dort irgendwelche nicht gekennzeichneten Drohnen, die dann schwer bewaffnet sind durch die Gegend fliegen, überlegst du dir auch dreimal, ob du da jetzt wirklich nah Flugzeuge hinterher schicken möchtest, um die abzuschießen oder ob du dann da mit deinen eigenen Piloten da aufs Spiel setzen möchtest?
Also ich meine, wir haben das ja schon gesehen, jetzt gerade in Libanon, also Israel-Libanon, wo eine Drohne in den israelischen Luftraum eingedrungen ist. Und die Israelis halt auch nicht so richtig wissen, wo die herkommt. Die haben eigenen Angaben zufolge erstmal versucht, den Controlling zu hacken, also um die Drohne zu übernehmen und zu landen. Und haben es wohl aber nicht geschafft, interessanterweise, was sie sehr frustriert hat. Und haben sie dann abgeschossen. Und nehmen sie jetzt halt auseinander und vermuten halt, dass es halt irgendwie die iranischen Ursprungs ist. Aber so richtig beweisen und belegen können sie es halt irgendwie nur anhand von Indizien. Und das wird halt die Norm werden. Also dass Drohnen von Playern kommen, wo halt irgendwie so ein bisschen unklar ist, wo die herkommen, was die der Ursprung ist. Und selbst wenn man weiß, wer die Drohne hergestellt hat, dann ist halt immer noch nicht klar, wer sie eigentlich kontrolliert hat. Also es kann auch eine geklaute Drohne sein oder eine, die irgendwie vom Schwarzmarkt kommt oder die gleichen Dinge mehr. Also das ist halt eine große Bandbreite von Möglichkeiten, weil da eben kein Pilot mehr drin sitzt. Oder kein Fahrer mehr drin sitzt, den man halt im Zweifel befragen oder an seinem Akzent erkennen kann, wo er jetzt ja kommt.
Und auf der anderen Seite ist, wenn du eine asymmetrische Kriegsführung wie jetzt die Vereinigten Staaten da führst gegen vielleicht nicht mal mehr Nationalstaaten, sondern Organisationen, sei es religiös motiviert oder vielleicht wirtschaftlich motiviert, ist ja dann die Antwort auf, sagen wir mal, US-amerikanischem Boden dann auch wieder eine total asymmetrische. Also auch die Flugzeuge da zu 9-11 zu captchern und dort in so Hochhäuser zu lenken, hätte auf eine Art und Weise auch anonym sein können. Also du hättest auch dann komplett den Ursprung verschleiern können. Und dort deine Ziele zu erreichen, indem du jetzt nicht mehr eine Armee vernichten musst, sondern einfach nur noch führende Köpfe, kann natürlich genauso zurückschlagen, dass am Ende man auch als, keine Ahnung, führende wirtschaftliche Persönlichkeit in der westlichen Welt dann plötzlich seine eigene Drohnenverteidigungsarmee braucht, um nicht von der Konkurrenz dort beniede gemacht zu werden oder von...
Da haben wir gerade irgendwie die Standarddrohnen irgendwie, oder die verbreiteten Drohnen haben irgendwie 15 Meter Flügelspannweite und sind halt relativ groß. Das heißt, die werden wahrscheinlich so ein, zwei Millionen kosten. Gibt es da Preise?
Kann man sagen? So eine aktuelle Grey Eagle kostet so zwischen 7 und 8 Millionen etwa.
Okay, die werden wir jetzt nicht zu Hause bauen, aber ich denke jetzt ans andere Ende der Skala, da gibt es halt diese Quadrocopter und so, die natürlich auch in den nächsten Jahren ein bisschen leistungsfähiger werden. Also ist das sozusagen auch eine Entwicklung stattfindet, dass sozusagen ein einzelner oder ein kleines Team, also gar nicht mal der Multimilliardär jetzt, sondern dass ein paar Leute sich so was bauen können?
Also ist halt vollständig absehbar. Die interessante Frage ist halt nur, wird es zu neuen Formen von Terrorismus führen? Meine wahrscheinliche Antwort ist erstmal nicht, weil das Problem halt weniger die Drohne ist als der Sprengstoff. Weil wenn man halt so eine Drohne hat, dann kann man zwar filmen oder irgendjemand erschrecken, aber wenn man nicht den Sprengstoff hat, dann ist da noch lange kein Terrorismus draus geworden. Und wenn man es wollte, dann hätte man auch ohne Drohne im Zweifel da sein Ziel erreichen können, sondern wir können eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass es halt wie mit all diesen Dingen ist, wo immer irgendwie Panik geschwommen wird, gesagt wird, die bösen Terroristen werden es machen. Also was ist hier, was hat man da, Bio Tower zum Beispiel, wo ja auch wieder so ein Klassiker, dass es am Ende halt wieder in ein Spiel der Nationalstaaten bleiben wird, die halt über die entsprechenden Ressourcen verfügen oder halt von ähnlich großen Organisationen, die Großkonzerne oder internationalen Organisationen oder Söldner Firmen und dass solche Akteure sich im Zweifel damit ausrüsten werden. Aber interessant wird halt, gerade im Inneren, wird zum Beispiel auch die Frage, was, wenn die Polizei halt nicht aufhört, bei Quadrocoptern mit Kameras, um halt die Ruhbschrauber zu ersetzen, sondern anfängt halt, nehmen wir mal an, die in fünf Generationen funktionsfähigen, zweieinigen Roboter halt irgendwie mit Trinkgass und Gummiknüppeln auszustatten, um halt Personal zu sparen. Oder halt einfach sehr viel mehr Personal am Ladegerät in der Halle zu haben, für den Fall, dass man es halt mal braucht. Da kommen dann schon interessante Fragen, nämlich, dass eine größere Drohnenarmee ist halt ein enormer Machtmultiplikator, den es so bisher nicht gab. Weil bisher muss man halt immer, gerade jetzt auch wenn man nicht von nicht tödlichen Einsätzen ausgeht, muss man halt immer Menschen überzeugen, dieses zu tun, sei es durch Gehaltszahlen, und sich in Trocknationen und so weiter.
Um uns ganz klar zu sagen, bei den Microwallen hast du auf beiden Seiten Menschen stehen. Und die sind natürlich dann auch dabei, aber die müssen auch dabei sein. Und ein Roboter kannst einfach sagen, lauf da hin und mach.
Also dann halt.
Dann halt, wenn es soweit ist. Über die Konsequenzen und das, was sozusagen zu tun noch kommen könnte, wenn man mit Kriegsmaschinerie, mit semi-autonomer oder autonomer Kriegsmaschinerie zu viel spielt, sprechen wir gleich noch. Jetzt gibt es erstmal auch das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Live und neu und gut. Wann genau und wo genau?
Fritzee.
Genau.
Cezar, Citizens und Timo Hauer, live von neu und gut, empfohlen von Fritz. Und das hört man um kurze halb zwölf. Nachricht mit Falko Wittich. Nach der tödlichen Prügel-Attacke am Berliner Alexanderplatz sind zwei Tatverdächtige wieder auf freiem Fuß. Das hat die Staatsanwaltschaft mitgeteilt. Der 19- und der 21-Jährige hatten sich gestern der Polizei gestellt. Ein Untersuchungsrichter sah bei dem 19-Jährigen keinen Haftgrund. Für den 21-Jährigen gab es zwar einen Haftbefehl, der wurde aber außer Vollzug gesetzt. Berlins Inn-Senator Henke sagte der Berliner Morgenpost, er sei mit der Entscheidung des Haftrichters unzufrieden und könne sie nicht verstehen. Die beiden Jugendlichen gehören zu einer Gruppe, die für den Tod eines 20-Jährigen verantwortlich gemacht werden. Ein Verdächtiger sitzt derzeit in Untersuchungshaft. Trinkwasser soll langfristig in Berlin um mindestens 15 Prozent billiger werden. Das haben die Regierungsfraktionen von SPD und CDU im Abgeordnetenhaus beschlossen. In dem Beschluss wird der Senat aufgefordert, alle Berliner Wasserkunden bereits in diesem Jahr, um pauschal insgesamt 60 Millionen Euro zu entlasten. Die Grünen nannten die Entlastung unzureichend. Das Bundeskartellamt hatte im Juni verfügt, dass die Berliner Wasserpreise in diesem Jahr deutlich billiger werden müssen. Die syrische Armee will für die Zeit des Islamischen Opferfests alle Militäreinsätze einstellen. Die Waffenruhe solle gemäß dem Vorschlag des UN-Sondergesandten Brahimi von Freitagmorgen an gelten und bis zum Ende der Feiern am Montag dauernd teilte die Armee mit. Die freie syrische Armee, der die meisten Rebellen angehören, erklärte, sie wolle sich ebenfalls an den Waffenstillstand halten. Andere Rebellenführer lehnten einen Waffenstillstand dagegen ab. UN-Generalsekretär Ban forderte Armee und Rebellen in Syrien auf, die Feuerpause tatsächlich einzuhalten. In der Fußball Europa League konnten drei deutsche Mannschaften am Abend Siege feiern. Borussia Mönchengladbach gewann zu Hause gegen Olympique Lyon mit 2 zu 0. Bayer Leverkusen siegte 4 zu 0 bei Rapid Wien und Hannover schaffte in Schweden einen 2 zu 1 Sieg gegen Helsingborg. Der VfB Stuttgart kam gegen den FC Kopenhagen nicht über ein 0 zu 0 Unentschieden hinaus.
Wetter.
Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen, wir haben derzeit in Berlin-Dalem 7 Grad, Prenzlberg meldet 8 Grad. In Angermünde und Neuropäen sind es 6 Grad, in Potsdam, Cottbus, Frankfurt und Wittenberge 7 Grad. In der Nacht weniger Wolken, es bleibt meist trocken. Tieftemperaturen liegen im Bereich von plus 3 bis minus 1 Grad. Am Tage dann im Süden teilweise wolkig, ansonsten heiter. Und es bleibt meist trocken bei maximal 5 bis 8 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin. Da haben wir die A100 in Richtung Wedding an einigen Stellen. Derzeit auf dem Stadtring Stau oder stockender Verkehr. Die A115 zwischen dem Kreuz Zehendorf und Spanischer Lehe. Da ist die Richtungsfahrbahn gesperrt wegen einer Baustelle bis 6 Uhr. Außerdem auf der Avus statt einwärts zwischen Spanischer Lehe und Hüttenweg ist derzeit nur eine spurfreie Stau haben wir ab Kreuz Zehendorf. A111 statt Autobahn statt einwärts. Bis morgen früh 5 Uhr Vollsperrungen zwischen Weidmanns-Lusterdam und am Festplatz. Gegen Mitternacht beginnt die Sperrung dann sogar noch ein Stück früher. Und zwar bereits an der Schulzendorfer Straße. Marzahn, die Hellersdorfer Straße statt auswärts zwischen alter Hellersdorfer Straße und Rieserstraße besteht nach einem Unfall Staugefahren. In Mitte gibt es Filmarbeiten, deswegen bis 6 Uhr morgen früh in der Kronenstraße zwischen Glinkerstraße und Charlottenburg. Sperrung der Straße in beiden Richtungen. Die A24 haben wir dann noch in Richtung Hamburg. Zwischen Dreigwittstockdorfer und Tankstelle Stolpe ist derzeit ein Schwertransport unterwegs, den ihr leider nicht überholen könnt. Und zum Schluss zur S-Bahn. Es gibt eine Signalstörung in Pankow-Heinersdorf. Deswegen auf den Linien S1, S2 und S8 Verspätungen und Teilausfälle. Die Linie S8, die verkehrt derzeit nur zwischen Zeuten Grünau und Kreisweiler Straße.
Gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz-Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an.
Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon zu Gast Rob Erdgeist und Frank. Hallo und willkommen zurück. Und wir haben jetzt noch nicht mal mehr eine halbe Stunde, um das Ganze zum Abschluss zu bringen, weil wir heute geredet haben. Das sind Kriegsmaschinen, autonome Kriegsmaschinen, also die sagen, die im Zweifel auch selbst denken soll, auch bekannt als Drohnen. Wir haben schon beschrieben die Geschichte der Wissenschaft, die dem Militär hilft, was Drohnen sind, wie sie funktioniert, wo sie eingesetzt werden. Und jetzt müssten wir eigentlich mal zu den Konsequenzen kommen. Also was genau wird uns da blühen in Zukunft mit diesen Kriegsmaschinen, die quasi keinen menschlichen Einsatz mehr brauchen?
Naja, wir müssen uns ein bisschen überlegen, welche Rolle der nicht Frieden oder Krieg in der zukünftigen Politik spielen wird. Und zumindest unsere momentanen Regierenden sind ja offensichtlich der Meinung, dass es immer wichtiger wird, dass sie halt in der Lage sein sollen, Einsätze irgendwo auf der Welt zu führen, wo gerade mal wieder Öl gefunden wurde. Oder irgendwie seltene Erden oder sonstige Dinge, die sie halt gerne hätten. Unser nächster Krieg, an dem die Bundeswehr auch teilnehmen soll, ist ja in Mali. Was ist da los? Also, worum es geht, ist wohl da die Befriedung der umliegenden Gegenden, weil da halt mal wieder islamistische Terroristen oder Leute, die als solche bezeichnet werden, unterwegs sein sollen. Worum es da eigentlich geht, habe ich mir noch nicht so genau angeguckt. Ich vermute mal, der Kontext, in dem der Bundesverteidigungsminister auch Waffenhäfte drohend forderte, ist dann eben auch genau so was, dass man sagen kann, wir müssen da keine Soldaten hinschicken und wir können also Einsätze fahren, bei denen wir als Bundeswehr oder als Bundesrepublik auch tödliche Gewalt ausüben können, ohne dass wir eigene Soldaten riskieren.
Das lässt sich ja im Inland bestimmt super verkaufen.
Genau, also da ist es halt auch interessant, so wenn man sich so die Kommentare anguckt. Ich hatte in einer VZ einen Artikel darüber geschrieben und bei vielen Kommentaren war da so, ja, aber es ist doch total super. So irgendwie wollen wir doch haben, dann können wir irgendwie endlich mal wieder da irgendwie unterwegs sein, ohne als Militär, ohne dass wir da irgendwie Soldaten in Buddybacks nach Hause bringen müssen. Und genau diese Art Einstellung wird halt dazu führen, dass es halt mehr Drohnen, mehr Drohnen einzugeben. Das zweite große Thema ist Grenzsicherung. Wir leben ja in einer Welt, wo bedingt durch Klimawandel und andere politische Veränderungen immer mehr Leute woanders hinwollen. Also sei es nun halt, dass sie von Mexiko und die Vereinigten Staaten wollen, oder dass sie von Nordafrika nach Europa wollen, oder von Südosteuropa nach EU-Europa. Klar ist halt diese Grenzen, wenn man die verteidigen will, dann wird es ganz schön schnell ganz schön hässlich. Also was wir da gesehen haben an der innerdeutschen Grenze, also mit Mauer und Stacheldraht und den damals relativ primitiven Selbstschussanlagen, die im Wesentlichen aus einer Patrone Hackschrot und einem Draht bestanden, der, wenn ein Draht berührt wurde, diese Hackschrot-Schießanlage ausgelöst hat. Und wenn man sich so mal zurückguckt, was das für ein riesiges Thema war, also wenn man so alte Spiegel anguckt oder so, diese Selbstschussanlagen war über Jahre hinweg das große Thema in der innerdeutschen Verhandlerei und Politik. Und dann gucken wir uns halt mal zum Beispiel Israel die Grenzen zum Grasastreifen oder zum Libanon an oder die nordkoreanische, südkoreanische Grenze und demnächst dann wohl auch die mexikanische, amerikanische, äusseramerikanische Grenze und da werden Systeme eingesetzt, die quasi autonom gesteuerte Maschinengewehre sind. Wie funktioniert das? Es funktioniert so, dass momentan da halt auch noch ein Mensch in der Loop ist, also halt noch ein Mensch, der Tötungsentscheidungen treffen soll. Das heißt also man hat da Sensoren, die sagen, okay in diesem Grenzabschnitt versucht gerade jemand drüber zu kommen. Sei es über geotektronische Sensoren, die Erschütterungen im Erdboden erfassen, über Kameras, Bewegungsmelder und solche Dinge und Millimeterradar und dann wird ein Maschinengewehrturm mit Kameras da hingerichtet, wo die Sensoren gesagt haben, da ist was, fährt dann genau auf diese Person der Personengruppe rein und alarmiert einen Operator und sagt, hier habe ich was. So und dann kann der halt entscheiden zu schießen oder erstmal einen Warnschluss abzugeben oder zu sagen Hände hoch auf den Boden legen oder was auch immer oder halt auf Full-Auto stellen und Full-Auto heißt halt irgendwie identifiziertes Ziel wird halt einfach erschossen. Und die Südkoreaner bauen ähnliche Systeme, die mobil sind, also die halt rumfahren sollen in Grenzabschnitten, in die sie jetzt nachdem es da die ersten Medienberichte gab vor ein paar Jahren und die Leute meinten so, naja so richtig toll ist es ja nicht, jetzt Logik einbauen, um zu erkennen, ob der, denjenigen, den sie da angetroffen, angerufen haben, seine Hände hebt, um sich zu ergeben. Und dann wird halt der Roboter halt den Gefangenen machen. Und solche Systeme, die halten, sagen wir mal Menschen, denen die Last abnehmen, halt auf unbewaffnete Flüchtlinge zu schießen, darum geht es ja meistens an Grenzen, die, denke ich mal, werden sich doch stark verbreiten.
Es ist dann auch spannend, ob der dann mitbekommt, dass so der Krieg vorbei ist oder die Grenze jetzt da gar nicht mehr existiert. Oder ob dann, wie die japanischen Soldaten auf den Inseln nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg, dann da noch plötzlich in irgendwelchen längst befriedigten Gebieten, du da von Roboter und Hobbs genommen wirst, die der Meinung sind, da jetzt Leute noch zusammentreiben zu müssen. So, was ja eigentlich spannend ist, ist, dass es ja, es sind ja am Ende auch wieder Computer. Es sind ja auch am Ende wieder dieselben Dinge, die bei dir zu Hause hässliche Bluescreens machen. Es sind genau dieselben Dinge, denen du jetzt auch noch irgendwelchen KI-Algorithmen anvertraust, solche Entscheidungen generell zu treffen. Es sind Tötungsmaschinen, die über Rückkanäle, die eventuell manipulierbar sind, über mehrere tausend Kilometer noch mal Rückfrage halten, zuweilen, die durch technische Manipulation vor Ort eventuell übernommen werden können. Wo du eine Telepräsenz dorthin dir durch diese Tötungsmaschine versuchst zu geben, wo du nicht mehr weißt, ob das jetzt wirklich alles der Realität entspricht. Ich bekomme ein Fernsehbild von dem, was diese Maschine denkt, was jetzt die Realität ist. Und die aktuelle Drohnenforschung geht dir dahin, dass die Algorithmen dieser künstlichen Intelligenzen den Menschen wieder nachweisen müssen, wie sie jetzt zu dieser Entscheidung gekommen sind. Warum sie glauben anhand welcher Parameter, dass das, was da im Sichtfeld ist, jetzt ein Terrorist ist, damit der Mensch diese Entscheidung nachvollziehen kann. Weil es wirklich ein großes Problem ist, dass was dir präsentiert wird am Monitor, ob du dem da einfach so vertraust und dann draufhältst oder ob dir was vorgegaukelt wird. Den Sensoren einer Drohne oder eines Killroboters kann man vielleicht durch ein vorgehaltenes Videobild sonst was vormachen und dann läuft da halt nur, keine Ahnung, eine harmlose Familie lang während der Operator da, der nur die Sensoren, der der Drohne hat, glaubt, der müsste jetzt los schlagen.
Gibt es denn Beispiele schon oder Berichte von Drohnenhacks?
Ich hatte gerade schon von der Geschichte aus Israel erzählt, wo die Israelis versucht haben, diese vermutete Iranische bzw. von einer Hisbollah gestellte Drohne zu übernehmen, was ihnen wohl nicht so ganz gelungen ist. Die Iraner haben behauptet, dass sie eine amerikanische Drohne, eine amerikanische Stelsdrohne gehackt und übernommen haben, wo eigentlich nicht ganz klar ist, ob das der Realität entspricht oder ob sie die mit anderen Mitteln runtergeholt haben. Klar ist jedenfalls, dass sie sie eingefangen haben und in der Turnhalle präsentieren konnten. Und es gibt auch vereinzelte Berichte aus den Konflikten, also Georgien und Abhazien, zumindest von mehr- oder minder erfolgreichen Versuchen, Drohnen zu übernehmen. Am Ende ist halt immer die Frage, wie viel Aufwand man da reinsteckt und wie gut halt die Absicherung der Kanäle, also der Steuerkanäle ist. Aber eben auch die Frage, wie gut ist dann eigentlich die Absicherung der Kontrollzentren? Man hat halt in den Drohnen-Kontrollzentren in den USA ganz normale Malware, also normale Viren gefunden, die sich da einfach eingefangen haben beim Games-Zocken auf ihren Windows-Computern, auf denen sie halt nebenbei dann halt auch ihre Drohnen geflogen haben.
Ich schlage mir gerade mit der Hand ins Gesicht.
Ja, und diese Frage des Übernehmens von Drohnen und der Kontrolle von Drohnen wird dann halt akut, wenn die Amerikaner mal gegen einen ernstzunehmenden Gegner antreten müssen. Also wenn sie halt gegen Iran oder China oder Russland tatsächlich aktiv werden und die auch so über eigene Drohnen verfügen, als auch über entsprechende Einheiten, die durchaus in der Lage sind, schlecht gesicherte Systeme zu übernehmen. Und da wird es dann halt interessant. Und die Frage halt, wie viel Autonomie brauchen wir in Drohnen, wird durch, wenn der Gegner auch Drohnen hat, unmittelbar verschärft. Weil man natürlich, wenn ein Computer eine Drohne steuert, dann ist er halt sehr viel schneller als ein Mensch. Der kann sehr viel schneller Entscheidungen treffen, auf sehr viel mehr Input reagieren, muss nicht erst Abwägungen treffen und den Anwalt fragen, ob er los schlagen kann.
Aber kommen wir nicht da zu einem Punkt, wo man sagen kann, möglicherweise sind die Drohnen doch was Gutes, weil man irgendwann den Menschen ganz rausnehmen kann und dann treten nur noch Drohnen gegeneinander an?
Naja, das wird eben interessant, die Frage, wie sieht dann eine Welt aus, in der sich Drohnen gegenseitig bekämpfen? Gucken wir denn nur noch zum Himmel und sehen, dass da irgendwie Roboter am Himmel sind, die sich gegenseitig bekriegen und gelegentlich runterfallen und dabei brennen? Oder wird eigentlich das Ziel weiter sein, Herrschaft über die Menschen auf dem Boden zu erringen? Oder sie dazu zu bringen, Dinge zu tun oder nicht zu tun? Also was ist eigentlich das Ziel von militärischer Auseinandersetzung dann?
Also sagen Sie, ein Science-Fiction-Szenario jetzt. Ne, achso, ja. Also was ich mir vorstelle ist, die Menschen eines Landstriches, also wo es da meinetwegen auch um Rohstoffe geht oder so, die arbeiten auf der Fölle in die Rohstoffe und der Drohnenkampf entscheidet halt, wo die Rohstoffe hingeliefert werden. Also quasi. Das wäre doch sozusagen eine sehr effektive...
Warum denn nicht gleich Drohnen und die Rohstoffe abbauen lassen?
Dann würden wir uns quasi selber überflüssig machen.
Oh super. Aber trotzdem gibt es ja dann Entscheider. Es gibt ja immer exponierte Persönlichkeiten in allen Gesellschaften, die anzugreifen, deutliche Lohnen da ist als jetzt nur, naja, so irgendwie Joe von der Straße anzugreifen. Und gegen die wird sich dann im Zweifel der Krieg dann eher noch richten. Dass man sich wirklich explizit Entscheider dahernimmt und versucht, durch das Bestrafen von Einzelnen oder durch das Töten von Einzelnen eine andere Gesellschaft komplett zu übernehmen. Das ist ja immer möglich. Also einfach nur Drohnen des Gegners zu bekämpfen, ist ja nun noch kein inherenter Wert an sich. Meistens hast du ja nicht einen Zwist mit dem Drohnen deines Opponenten, sondern mit wirklich den Führern oder Teilen der Bevölkerung.
Ja, aber das ist doch super, dann sperren wir die Führer mit ihren Drohnen auf ein eingesperrtes Areal und dann erledigt sich der Recht von selbst.
Also es gibt da einen schönen Stanislaw Lem-Roman, den ich bei dieser Gelegenheit mal den Hörern als Herz legen möchte. Das heißt, der Flop ist ein Roman aus der Ion Tiri-Reihe, der also doch eigentlich mit so zu den besten Werken von Lem zählt. Und da ist das Szenario so, dass die Menschheit, der Kriege überdrüssig geworden, beschlossen hat, dass sie ihr gesamtes Waffenarsenal auf den Mond verlagert, also dass jeder Staat bekommt auf dem Mond ein abgestecktes Areal und in dem kann er vorautomatische Waffenfabriken unterbringen. Und der Mond wird zur Toten Zone erklärt, also es gibt halt keine Kommunikation mit diesen Waffenfabriken auf dem Mond. Und wenn irgendein Staat sagt, er will jetzt aber seine Waffen haben, dann erfahren alle anderen Staaten auch davon. Also dann können die halt auch sagen, sie wollen ihre Waffen haben. Und das geht halt eine ganze Weile gut so. Und ja, das ist halt irgendwie paradiesisch und friedlich. Aber irgendwann wird dann halt den Leuten so ein bisschen mulmig, weil sie halt wissen wollen, ob sie dann zum einen haben sie denn jetzt eigentlich noch Waffen da oben oder haben die evolutionären Algorithmen, die da oben jetzt rumwirkeln, irgendwas anderes beschlossen? Ich will jetzt mal nicht den Plot spoilern. Jedenfalls schicken sie dann halt ihren Tee-Rider hoch, der mal nachgucken soll, was denn jetzt eigentlich los ist. Und genau dieses Szenario ist natürlich wieder ein Name indiziert des Buches der Flop, es ist halt natürlich schief gegangen. Aber es ist sehr lesenswert, weil man dieses Szenario mal in aller Tiefe, insbesondere halt auch in den Auswirkungen von künstlicher Intelligenz, von einem der besten Sci-Fi Autoren, die wir jetzt so hatten, durchgespielt lesen will.
So jetzt haben wir, sagen wir zum Thema, gibt es eigentlich noch zwei wichtige Fragen. Die eine ist, jetzt habt ihr sehr viel in den vergangenen zwei Stunden zu Drohnen erzählt und auch wenn das eine schöne Vorstellung ist, vermute ich, dass ihr nicht im Operationszentrum der Amis wart und sozusagen die Drohnen da selber auseinander genommen habt. Was sind Informationsquellen, wenn man sich selber zu diesem Thema informieren will?
Es gibt eine Menge in der Presse dazu. Da muss man natürlich sehr sorgfältig lesen, weil viel davon halt durchaus auch einfach Propaganda ist. Es gibt jetzt gerade im Kontext des amerikanischen Wahlkampfs und des damit zusammenhängenden, auf die Brust, Trommels der Amerikaner über die Tötung von Bin Laden einiges an Sachen, die da so berichtet werden in der Weiheit, also beziehungsweise Weiheit online. Gibt es immer wieder relativ ausführliche Berichte zu Drohnen, Drohntechnologie und Entwicklungen, die halt auch sehr, naja, sagen wir, meteorisch und industriell komplex zentrisch sind. Ansonsten gibt es bei globalsecurity.org, das ist eine NGO, die sich halt mit diesen Themen beschäftigt was. Und ansonsten gibt es die International Campaign Against Robotic Arms, also die Kampagne gegen Kriegsroboter, die aus der Kampagne gegen Landminen hervorgegangen ist in Großbritannien. Die haben sehr ausführliche Informationsseiten und so, die auch die wissenschaftliche, also den wissenschaftlichen Zweig davon betrachten. Ansonsten gibt es, um so den Stand der Technik so ein bisschen abzuwägen und wohin die gerade gehen, gibt es die, glaube ich auch Glow Security, hatte eine Studie freigekämpft von den Amerikanern. Die heißt Autonomie in DoD Systems, also Autonomität in Systemen des Verteidigungsministeriums der Amerikaner, wo sie auf 160 Seiten dieses ganze Problem auswalzen, was sie haben, wie sie Drohnen einsetzen wollen, welche Doktrin sie haben, was die Fähigkeiten sind, wo sie hinwollen, was so die unterschiedlichen Grad an Autonomität sein sollen, wie die Bewaffnung aussehen soll und wovor sie so Angst haben. Und da stehen ein paar sehr erstaunliche Dinge drin, unter anderem, dass die größte Furcht, die sie haben, sind natürlich die Chinesen. Also schreiben sie natürlich nicht so, aber sie reden halt von einem Potential Enemy, also einem potentiellen Feind, der möglicherweise Drohnen bauen könnte, die halt keine Hemmungen haben, also die halt keine Kriegsrechtseinschränkungen haben. Und da sagen sie, okay, da kann man sich dann eigentlich nur mit anderen Drohnen dagegen verteidigen, weil der Mensch ist halt nicht schnell genug dafür. Das heißt, wir befinden uns schon auf so einem Rennen nach unten aus Frucht, dass der andere radikaler sein könnte beim Einsatz von Autonomie. Das ist dann durchaus eine lesenswerte Sache. Ansonsten, was das Handfiction angeht, Daniel Suarez hat ein Buch geschrieben, Kill Decision ist jetzt so literarisch nicht sein bestes, aber auf jeden Fall, was jetzt so die Zukunftsszenarien angeht, von autonomen Drohenschwermen doch sehr plastisch und sehr eindrücklich und eindringlich, kann man doch durchaus lesen auch.
Dann kann man sich da weiterbilden, wie ist jetzt, also was machen wir jetzt damit? Also ich meine, für Vorratssatenspeicherung oder Akta oder was, da kann man auch so sagen, Massen symbolisieren, hat man jetzt zu sagen, habt ihr da irgendwie sozusagen so eine Bürgerpflicht, die ihr kompliziert, so über Drohnen muss man auch aufpassen, oder ist das sowas, da steht man eher neben, guckt sich das an, dann kann man ja nix machen.
Na ja, am Ende sind Drohnen, die in unserem Namen durch die Gegend fliegen, am Ende müssen die genauso demokratisch legitimiert werden wie Bundeswehreinsätze im Ausland. Und natürlich hat man da als Bürger erst mal die Pflicht, sich zu informieren. Man soll mal dahergehen und schauen, was die Entwicklung ist. Wenn wir Wehrpflichtige haben, die Wehrpflichtarmee extra als Bürger in Uniform konzipiert worden, damit da noch Leute mit Gewissen durch die Gegend marschieren, die dann vielleicht vor dem Mord noch mal nachdenken, ist es bei Drohnen und bei dem kompletten Outsourcing, dieser Entscheidung an irgendeinen Algorithmus, dann vielleicht dann uns zu informieren und zu schauen, ob wir das wollen?
Also konkret denke ich, mal geht es gerade darum zu verhindern, dass die Bundeswehr ohne weitere Reflexe und Bewachtete Drohnen bekommt. Und man auf jeden Fall da klare Beschränkungen einziehen muss, die sagen, der Einsatz militärischer Gewalt, auch wenn er von Drohnen ausgeht, kann nicht in so einem unregulierten Grauzonenbereich stattfinden. Insbesondere nicht in so einem Bereich wie Somatand, die CAA tut. Die Frage, die sich danach anschließt, ist natürlich, inwieweit ist Deutschland als führendes Rüstungsexportland? Und wie streben sie an, gerade auch bei Drohnenführen zu werden? Inwieweit will man sich persönlich daran beteiligen? Sei es im Rahmen von Universitäts- und sonstigen Forschungsprojekten oder durch Wahl seines Arbeitgebers möchte man an solchen Technologien teilnehmen? Oder möchte man lieber sagen, okay, da hab ich jetzt keine Lust drauf? Und auch wenn da Search and Rescue dransteht, dann erlaube ich mir trotzdem mal zu hinterfragen, was eigentlich mit dieser Technologie jetzt passiert.
Eine Anführung in Kriegsmaschinen haben wir euch in vergangenen zwei Stunden gegeben. Wir haben natürlich nicht alles geschafft, aber ich glaube, es war ein Rundumblick über das Thema und ihr habt jetzt auch gehört, wo ihr euch nochmal genauer darüber informieren könnt. Es wird natürlich auch ein Podcast zu dieser Sendung geben, wo man das alles nochmal genau nachhören kann. Sobald Chaosradio.de wieder am Start ist, wird er auch dort verfügbar sein. Hier auf Fritz wird es ihn auf jeden Fall noch in dieser Nacht geben. Vielen Dank allen Beteiligten für die interessanten Einblicke. Möchte ich das jetzt wirklich sagen. Und zum Abschluss der Sendung noch ein paar Goodies, die sozusagen mit dem Umfeld zu tun haben, indem wir uns hier bewegen, nämlich dem Chaosradio, des Chaos Computer Clubs. Da soll ja möglicherweise gegen Ende des Jahres möglicherweise eine Veranstaltung stattfinden. Ist das korrekt?
Die findet nicht nur möglicherweise statt, die findet ziemlich sicher zwischen dem 27. und 30. Dezember statt. Diesmal abweichend in Hamburg. Wir haben, nachdem das BCC in Berlin für den Ansturm zu klein geworden ist, das Haus CCH, den Kongress Center Hamburg, gemietet und werden dort dann zu den üblichen Zeiten zwischen den Jahren Wiederhacker aus aller Welt erwarten. Wir haben gerade 290 Vortragseinreichungen, von denen wir knapp 100 auswählen. Das spricht dann schon mal für Qualität in den Vorträgen. Und wir haben diesmal Platz. Das heißt, dass viele Leute, die in den letzten Jahren gar nicht erst versucht haben, ein Ticket zu besorgen, dieses Jahr doch beruhigt dort. Es gibt Tickets. Es gibt Tickets und keine Ticketlotterie.
Also Vorträge habt ihr jetzt schon, da kann man nichts mehr einreichen. Wenn man da irgendwie mitmachen will, gibt es da noch Möglichkeiten?
Ja, natürlich. Wir haben mit den neuen Möglichkeiten ein Haus, was wir so noch nie bespielt haben. Mit all den Risiken, aber auch mit den Möglichkeiten, die man so hat. Wir wollen dieses Jahr ausprobieren, mal das Konzept einer Assembly, was so ungefähr wie ein Village auf einem Camp funktionieren soll. Das heißt, in den letzten Jahren ging der Trend eher so dahin, dass das Hackcenter, was ja so ursprünglich der größte Anteil beim Kongress gewesen ist, wo man in seiner Community zusammensaß und mal auch an einem Projekt gehackt hat, wenn man sich sonst das Jahr über nicht gesehen hat, das ist ja ein bisschen in den Hintergrund getreten. Der Fokus hat sich mehr auf den Besuch der Vorträge verschoben. Wir wollen dieses Jahr mit den Assemblies versuchen, wieder Communities anzulocken, die sich zusammensetzen sollen, die auch als Anlaufstelle für Interessierte dort fungieren. Und die bekommen dann, wenn sie sich vorher anmelden, doch schon ziemlich entspannten Platz zu weihen, sogar am Fenster zugewiesen. Und sollen dann...
Versprich nicht zu viel.
Sollen natürlich auch vorher die Werbetrommel rühren, dass sie dort als Ansprechpartner für ihr Projekt da sind, dass sie dort auch selber dann wieder eine Art Homebase haben für ihre Community, was in den letzten Jahren aus Platzgründen immer schwieriger geworden ist.
Okay, da gibt es also viel Platz, den ihr auch noch selber erfüllen könnt. Wenn ich dahin will, wo kann ich da informationsmäßig so?
Das Kongress-Wiki ist gestern online gegangen. Und unter Events.ccc.de gibt es rechts so einen Link in dieses Wiki. Das ist ziemlich einfach zu finden.
Und da sonst noch Informationen zu, wie es mit den Assemblies gemeint ist, wo es Karten gibt und Hotels und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Am besten Events.ccc.de, da findet ihr alle Informationen.
Genau, und der 29c3 dieses Jahr findet unter dem Motto Not My Department statt, was eine Referenz an Werner von Braun ist, der paraphrasiert, nachdem er gefragt worden ist, warum er mit den Nazis kollaboriert hat, um dort Raketen herzustellen, mit denen Menschen getötet worden sind und warum er der Zwangsarbeiter aus den KZ eingesetzt hat, gemeint hat, dass ich bin doch nur Wissenschaftler und ich sorge eigentlich nur dafür, dass die Raketen in die Luft kommen, aber wo sie landen, das ist nicht mein Metier, das ist Not My Department.
Die Chaosradio Sendung, die heute stattfindet, also quasi bekommt ein viertägiges Kongresseeignis in Hamburg dieses Jahr. Vielen Dank euch noch mal, vielen Dank euch fürs Zuhören. Ich übergebe jetzt an Henrik Schröder, der euch hier Punk-Musik um die Ohren hauen wird, bis sie bluten vielleicht, vielleicht auch ein bisschen. Vielleicht weiß ich es nicht genau, aber er wird es euch bestimmt gleich selber sagen. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich habe nur noch eine wichtige Nachricht für euch. Macht immer schön eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.